हेलो गाइ वेलकम टू आवर
youtube1 मेरा नाम है आयुष पाठक और आज हम
लोग करने वाले हैं नेटवर्क सिक्योरिटी का
डे 12 ठीक है तो आपको ऑलरेडी पता होगा कि
डे 11 तक नेटवर्क सिक्योरिटी के सारे
लेक्चर हमारे youtube1 पे ऑलरेडी अपलोड कर
दिए गए हैं और मैं उम्मीद करता हूं कि
आपने डे 11 तक सारे लेक्चर कंपलीटली देखे
होंगे सब चीजें ढंग से समझी होंगी ठीक है
तो आज हम यहां पर करने वाले हैं डे 12 तो
पहले मैं आपको बता दूं कि साथ में यहां पर
लाइव में अगर आप यहां पर लाइव सेक्शन में
आएंगे तो आपको बेस्ट की सीरीज भी मिल
जाएगी जो कि सचिन सर द्वारा कि करवाई जा
रही है ठीक है डेट 12 तक पहुंच चुके हैं
हम लोग इस पे तो आप इसको भी साथ में फॉलो
कर सकते हैं और नेटवर्क सिक्योरिटी वाला
तो साथ में कुछ-कुछ टाइम इंटरवल पे आता ही
रहता है ठीक है तो आप दोनों सीरीज को साथ
में कंटिन्यू कर सकते हैं और प्रैक्टिस कर
सकते हैं और जो भी आप प्रैक्टिस कर सकते
हैं कर रहे हैं उसको आप
भी लेटेस्ट अपडेट होंगे यहां पर मिलते
रहेंगे ठीक है और लिन पेज प ध्यान से आपको
यहां पर एक बेल आइकन मिलेगा उस पर टैप
करके आपको ऑल न्यू पोस्ट सेलेक्ट करके
इसको सेव कर लेना है ताकि आपको सारे पोस्ट
का जो है नोटिफिकेशन मिलता रहे और आप
हमारा एप्लीकेशन डाउनलोड कर सकते हैं
जिसमें आपको एक्सक्लूसिव ऑफर्स मिलेंगे
मतलब जो हमारे अभी कोर्सेस लच है या फिर
जो अपकमिंग कोर्सेस आने वाले हैं ठीक है
उसपे आपको एक्सक्लूसिव डिस्काउंट या फिर
जो भी बेनिफिट्स हो सकते हैं वो आपको
एप्लीकेशन प सबसे पहले मिलेंगे ठीक है तो
हमारे ए एप्लीकेशन को प् स्टोर से जरूर
डाउनलोड कर लीजिएगा चलिए तो आज के लेक्चर
को स्टार्ट करते हैं ठीक है हम लोगों ने
लास्ट क्लास में नेटवर्क सर्विसेस वाला
रूम किया था अब हम लोग नेटवर्क सर्विसेस
टू वाला रूम करने वाले हैं ठीक है तो
नेटवर्क सर्विसेस वन वाला हमने कर लिया था
टू वाला अब हम करने वाले हैं पहले मैं टैक
बॉक्स को यहां पर स्टार्ट कर देता
हूं य पर अटैक ब जब तक स्टार्ट हो रहा है
तो हम बात कर लेते हैं कि हम लोग क्या
करने वाले हैं अच्छे तरीके से ठीक है तो
पहले हमने क्या किया था हमने नेटवर्क
सर्विसेस वन वाले रूम में कुछ बेसिक जैसे
एफटीपी जैसे सर्विसेस का एन्यूमरेशन और
एक्सप्लोइटेशन समझा था ठीक है हम तीन
स्टेप में काम कर रहे थे पहले हम समझ रहे
थे कि वो सर्विस है क्या फिर हम समझ रहे
थे उसमें इवेशन कैसे करना है फिर हम देख
रहे थे कि उसके एक्सप्लोइटेशन का क्या
तरीका है ठीक है आज भी हम वही चीजें करने
वाले हैं पर आज हम कुछ ऐसे प्रोटोकॉल को
देखने वाले हैं जोक उतने कॉमन नहीं होंगे
या फिर आपको सीटीएस में उतनी आसानी से
इनमें अवेलेबिलिटी नहीं मिलेगी कि आपका
पहला जो निगाह है वो इन पे नहीं जाता होगा
ठीक है आज हम उन प्रोटोकॉल्स की बात करने
वाले हैं तो यहां पर कनेक्शन का लिखा है
कि आप अपना या तो टैग बॉक्स चालू कर दीजिए
या फिर अपना ओपन वीपीएन से सब कुछ सेटअप
कर लीजिए तो वो तो कर लीजिएगा ठीक है और
आप रूम मेरे साथ कीजिएगा मतलब जो मैं कर
रहा हूं उस साथ साथ करिएगा अगर ये रूम
फ्री होता है तो पेड होता है तो कोई बात
नहीं आप साथ में देख सकते हैं ठीक है चलिए
अंडरस्टैंडिंग एनएफएस तो पहला हमारा जो
प्रोटोकॉल यूज मतलब जिस प्रोटोकॉल के बारे
में हम लोग पहले समझने वाले हैं वो है
एनएफएस ठीक है इसको मैं क्लोज कर देता हूं
पहले चलिए अब एनएफएस मतलब नेटवर्क फाइल
सिस्टम ठीक है ये एक ऐसा प्रोटोकॉल है जो
कि आप कह सकते हैं कुछ कुछ एसएमबी की तरह
काम करता है मतलब ये भी आपकी चीजों को
शेयर ही करता है आपके डॉक्यूमेंट को या
डायरेक्टरी को शेयर करता है ठीक है एज अ
शेयर अवेलेबल कराता है ब इसमें डिफरेंस ये
है कि ये फाइल सिस्टम की तर एक करता है
कहने का मतलब क्या कि आप जैसे मान लीजिए
कोई कंप्यूटर है ठीक है वो अपने किसी
लोकेशन कीसी डायरेक्टरी को शेयर कर रहा है
तो आप एज अ नेटवर्क क्लाइंट उस नेटवर्क
क्लाइंट की तरह आप चाहे ऑथेंटिकेटेड हो या
जैसे भी हो ठीक है आप उन उनके उस
डायरेक्टरी को अपने सिस्टम पर माउंट कर
सकते हैं अब इसका मतलब क्या है अगर आपको
क्लियर नहीं समझ में आ र तो मैं आपको इसको
वाइट बोर्ड समझाने की कोशिश करता हूं ताकि
आपको य पर बेटर तरीके से समझ में
आए आराम से चिल रहना है समझना है आराम से
कोई डाउट होता हैम प पूछ सकते हैं कमेंट
में पूछ सकते पूछ सकते हैं ठीक है कोई उसम
दिक्कत नहीं है यहां पर ये इसको रिमूव कर
देता
हूं चलिए ठीक है बताता हूं य कैसे करना है
ओके सो एनस की बात कर रहे थे हम लोग एस
में क्या है एनस में जैसे मान लीजिए य का
एक सिस्टम है ठीक है यह आपका एक सिस्टम है
जिस पर एनएफएस की सर्विस रन हो रही है तो
आप कह सकते हैं कि आपका ये क्या है एक
एनएफएस आपका ये एक
एनस सर्वर है ठीक है आपका यह एक एनस सर्वर
है अब यह दो से तीन शेयर्स को अवेलेबल करा
रहा है ठीक है अब इसके शेयर्स क्याक है
बताता हूं आपको जैसे मान लीजिए यह अपने
इसका कोई यूजर है ठीक है मान लीजिए इसकी
कोई यूजर है लीज नाम की तो ये अपनी होम
स्ल लीजा वाली डायरेक्टरी को जो है
राइटिंग प ध्यान मत दीजिएगा थोड़ा सा ठीक
है यह होम स्ल ली जो डायरेक्टरी है ठीक है
इसको शेयर कर रहा है साथ में यह
होम
स्लश आयुष वाली जो डायरेक्टरी है उसको भी
शेयर कर रहा है ठीक है और यहां पर यह मान
लीजिए स्ल ईटीसी को शेयर कर रहा है ठीक है
यह दो ये तीन शेयर्स इसमें जो है टोटल
अवेलेबल है अब हम एज अ नेटवर्क क्लाइंट
ठीक है हम क्या है एक एनएफएस क्लाइंट है
हम ठीक है हम एक एनएफएस क्लाइंट है मतलब
हम एक ऐसे बंदे हैं जिनके सिस्टम प एनएफएस
क्लाइंट इंस्टॉल्ड है मतलब हम एनएफएस से
इंटरेक्ट कर सकते हैं अब हम क्या करेंगे
हम कुछ यूटिलिटीज यानी कुछ टूल्स का
इस्तेमाल करके इससे रिक्वेस्ट करेंगे मान
लीजिए हमें इनमें से कोई एक स्पेसिफिक
शेयर में इंटरेस्ट है मान लीजिए हम स्ल
होम स्ल आयुष में इंटरेस्ट है ठीक है हमें
ये वाला शेयर चाहिए अपने डिवाइस पे तो हम
यहां पर एक रिक्वेस्ट करेंगे हम यहां पर
इस एनएफएस सर्वर से एक रिक्वेस्ट करेंगे
ठीक है एक रिक्वेस्ट करेंगे और ये
रिक्वेस्ट होगी माउंट रिक्वेस्ट ठीक है ये
रिक्वेस्ट होगी कौन सी रिक्वेस्ट माउंट
रिक्वेस्ट यानी माउंट करने के लिए हम एक
रिक्वेस्ट करेंगे इस प्रोसेस को क्या कहते
हैं इस प्रोसेस को कहते हैं माउंटिंग ठीक
है हम रिक्वेस्ट करेंगे आप चाहे
क्रेडेंशियल देखके करें या जैसे भी करें
और फिर यहां पर रिस्पांस होगा ओके ठीक है
अगर ये एक्सेप्ट होता है सही तरीके से सब
कुछ वर्क कर रहा है तो आपका जो एनस मतलब
आपका जो शेयर है स् होम आयुष ये आपके
सिस्टम में माउंट हो जाएगा अब आप सिस्टम प
कहां माउंट करना चाहते हैं वो आपकी मर्जी
है वो आप जो भी टूल या यूटिलिटी का
इस्तेमाल कर रहे होंगे माउंट करते वक्त वो
आप वहां पे स्पेसिफाई कर देंगे ठीक है तो
हम इसका प्रैक्टिकल कर देखेंगे अभी लेकिन
ऊपर समझाने के लिए मैंने आपको ये चीज डिमन
श्रेशन था वो दिखा दिया ठीक है तो उम्मीद
करता हूं ये आपको समझ में आ गया होगा चलिए
मेरे ख्याल से पेन मुझे थोड़ी थिक सेलेक्ट
करनी चाहिए
थी कोई बात चलिए ठीक है इस तरीके से एफएस
जो है वो वर्क करता है यहां पर देख लेते
हैं कुछ एक्स्ट्रा चीज आपके लिए लिखी हो
ठीक है यहां पर कोई भी देखिए इफ समवन वांस
टू एक्सेस फाइल यूजिंग एस एस से आप फाइनली
क्या करेंगे एक फाइल एक्सेस करेंगे ना
मतलब आप ये जो आपका लोकेशन है इसको आप
यहां पर एक बार माउंट कर लेते हैं माउंट
करने बा आप क्या करेंगे कोई फाइल ऑपरेशन
करेंगे एक्सेस करेंगे ये सब करेंगे तो हर
एक जो एस कॉल है उसको क्याक पैरामीटर
चाहिए या उसकी बात हो रही है ठीक है देखिए
एर और हा एक चीज और यहां पर आरपीसी सर्विस
का यूज होता है देखिए य पर लिखा गा द
माउंट सर्विस विल देन एक्ट टू कनेक्ट टू द
रिवेंट माउ काउंट डेमन यूजिंग आरपीसी ठीक
है आरपीसी जो है सर्विस का इस्तेमाल हो
रहा है कनेक्ट करने के लिए मतलब आपका जो
क्लाइंट है वो आरपीसी सर्विस का इस्तेमाल
कर रहा है
चलिए हर एक कॉल का यहां प देखिए एक चीज और
ठीक है यूजर के पास परमिशन है कि नहीं है
या जो भी चीजें हैं ये चेक करने के बाद
ठीक है ये एक फाइल हैंडल रिटर्न करता है
और फाइल हैंडल यूनिक
आइडेंटिफिकेशन
चाहिए ठीक है नेम ऑफ द फाइल टू बी एजिस्ट
कौन सी फाइल आपको एक्स्ट करनी है यूजर की
आईडी और ग्रुप की आईडी की परमिशन चेक करने
के लिए ठीक है ये चार चीजों की जरूरत होती
है कॉल में तो ये आप प्रोवाइड नहीं करते
एकएक करके ये इंटरनल वर्किंग है ठीक है आप
इसके वर्किंग के बारे में अच्छे से पढ़
सकते हैं यहां पर ये लिंक दी हुई है इससे
पढ़ सकते हैं आप या फिर आप
जाएगा ठीक है चलिए आगे बढ़ते हैं पर
क्वेश्चन देख लेते हैं क्वेश्चन जितने भी
मैं देख रहा हूं आपको आंसर मन में सोचना
है उसका कि क्या हो सकता है ठीक है और
आंसर आपको खुद से करना है भले आपके पास
अगर ये रूम पेड भी होता है मान लीजिए और
आप एक्सेस नहीं कर सकते तो आप मन में आंसर
करिए कोई दिक्कत नहीं है ठीक है चलिए एनफ
स्टैंड फॉर
व्ट चलिए ये आंसर हो गया व्ट प्रोसेस अलाउ
एंड एफेस क्लाइंट टू इंटरेक्ट विद द रिमोट
डायरेक्टरी एज दो इट वास अ फिजिकल डिवाइस
ठीक है इसका मतलब ये है कि उस प्रोसेस को
क्या कहा जाता है ठीक है जो कि एनएफएस
क्लाइंट यानी हमें यहां पर जो थी एनएफएस
क्लाइंट हमें अलाउ करती है अलाउ टू
इंटरेक्ट विद रिमोट डायरेक्टरी यानी रिमोट
डायरेक्टरी से इंटरेक्ट करने की परमिशन
देती है या उसको हम हमारे लिए एक्सेसिबल
करती है ठीक है जैसे कि वो एक फिजिकल
डिवाइस लगाओ मतलब माउंट करने का मतलब क्या
है जैसे आप पेन ड्राइव माउंट करते हैं पेन
ड्राइव लगाते हैं तो आपके सिस्टम पे उसका
एकदम लोकेशन आ जाता है ना जैसे आपके
सिस्टम पेही लगी है वो वही चीज तो खैर वो
तो आपके सिस्टम पे ही लगी है पर ये आपके
सिस्टम प तो लगी नहीं है पर माउंट करने के
बाद आपको ऐसे ही एक लगता है जैसे वो आपके
सिस्टम प लगी हुई है कोई डिस्क है ठीक है
तो इस प्रोसेस को क्या कहते कहते हैं
माउंटिंग ठीक है तो उसका आंसर होना चाहिए
चलिए व्ट डज एनएफएस यूज टू रिप्रेजेंट
फाइल्स एंड डायरेक्टरीज ऑन द सर्वर यहां
पर एस क्या यूज करता है एनस सर्वर जो फाइल
डायरेक्टरी अवेलेबल है ठीक है उनको
रिप्रेजेंट करने के लिए तो क्या होता है
फाइल
हैंडल्स चलिए व्हाट प्रोटोकॉल डज एफएस यूज
टू कम्युनिकेट बिटवीन द सर्वर एंड द
क्लाइंट सर्वर और क्लाइंट के बीच में
कम्युनिकेशन के लिए कौन सा जो है
प्रोटोकॉल य होता है मैंने आपको बता था
आरपीसी ठीक है चलिए व्ट टू पीस ऑफ यूजर
डाटा डज द एनएफ सर्वर टेक्स ए पैरामीटर
फॉर कंट्रोलिंग यूजर परमिशन मतलब जब हम
कॉल कर रहे होते हैं ठीक है जब हम कॉल कर
रहे होते हैं मतलब इसको थ करता हूं ठीक है
जब हम एस क्लाइंट ठीक है ये कलर कुछ और
सेलेक्ट है
क्या चलिए जब हम एस क्लाइंट ठीक है कोई
कॉल कर रहे होते हैं तो हम क्या देते हैं
हम देते हैं अपनी यूजर
आईडी
ग्रुप दोनों आईडी देते हैं हम ठीक है यूजर
आईडी ग्रुप आईडी और हम क्या दे थे फाइल
हैंडल दे रहे थे फाइल
हैंडल ठीक है हम फाइल हैंडल दे रहे थे और
अपना क्या दे रहे थे एक चीज और दे रहे थे
याद करिए क्या चीज था फाइल का नेम ठीक है
जो फाइल हम एक्सेस करनी है ठीक है तीन चार
दे रहे थे तो यहां पर सिटेक्स केथ लग रहा
है कि ये यूजर आईडी ग्रुप आईडी होना चाहिए
य
पर य पर स्पेस था आई थ सॉरी ओके ये आंसर
भी हो गया ठीक है चलिए कन विंडोज एनस
सर्वर शेयर फाइल्स विद नक् क्लाइट इसका
आंसर सोचिए ये तीन नेक्स्ट क्वेश्चन का
आंसर आपको सोचना है कक ये तीन क्वेश्चन
नहीं दो का सोचिए ठीक है तो आंसर क्या
होगा अभी मैंने आपको बताया था कि कोई भी
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम मतलब विज
काम हो जाएगा ठीक है चलिए इसको देख लेते
हैं
एफेस
वर्जन लच इन
2016 य हमारा 4.2 लिख के आ रहा है 4.2
डालते य पर होली सही आंसर होना चाहिए चलिए
हो गया तो आपको समझ में आ गया य पर की
नेटवर्क फाइल सिस्टम वा प्रोटोकॉल है वो
वर्क कैसे कर रहा है ठीक है अभी हमका
प्रैक्टिकल देखेंगे तो उसम आपको टेंशन
लेने की को जरूरत नहीं है ठीक है अब बात
करते हैं नरेट एनएफएस प पहले इस मशीन को
स्टार्ट कर देते हैं ताकि जो भी हमारा आगे
चैलेंज होगा इसको हम लोग यहां पर देख
लेंगे ठीक है अटैक्स बॉक्स भी चालू कर ही
देते हैं यार चालू तो था ही वैसे इसको
यहां पर ओपन कर लेते हैं हम
लोग चलिए ये भी ओपन हो चुका है
हमारा अब आ जाते हैं एन्यूमरेशन पे ठीक है
तो बेसिक अगेन यहां पर एन्यूमरेशन
डेफिनेशन जो मैं आपको कितनी बार बता चुका
हूं तो इसको बताने की को जरूरत तो है नहीं
ठीक है एशन क्या होता है ये आपको बता है
अच्छे से अब यहां पर एक यूटिलिटी की बात
हो रही है पैकेज की ठीक है एनएफएस कॉमन अब
ये एनएफएस कॉमन पैकेज क्या है एनएफएस कॉमन
एक ऐसा पैकेज है ठीक है आपके नक् में आपको
मिल जाएगा इंस्टॉल कर सकते हैं आप ठीक है
जिसमें बहुत सारी यूटिलिटी होंगी जो आपके
काम आएंगी एफएस से इंटरेक्ट करने के लिए
जैसे यहां पर आपका हो गया एलडी मैडी ठीक
है या mount.nfs ठीक है या लकडी इस तरीके
से अलग-अलग जो शो माउंट ठीक है इस तरीके
के टूल्स का आप इस्तेमाल करेंगे ये सब
आपको अलग-अलग इंस्टॉल करने की जरूरत नहीं
है ये आपको सीधे अगर आप पैकेज इंस्टॉल
करते हैं एटी इंस्टॉल एएएस हान कॉमन से तो
आपके ये सारे पैकेज इंस्टॉल हो जाएंगे ये
आपके अटैक बॉक्स में पहले से इंस्टॉल्ड
आएंगे नक्स में भी होंगे ठीक है अगर आपके
में नहीं है तो आप इंस्टॉल कर सकते हैं ये
कमांड डल के सीधे ठीक है चलिए इंस्टॉल्ड
है फिलहाल तो हमें कोई दिक्कत उसमें नहीं
है अब इसको ीचे कर सकते हैं पेस्ट करके
अगर आप इसको उठा के पेस्ट करेंगे यहां
पर पेस्ट करेंगे मैं ए लिख देता हूं आगे
तो यहां पर ये ऑलरेडी इंस्टॉल्ड आएगा ठीक
है देखिए इज ऑलरेडी द न्यूवेस्ट वर्जन तो
हमें यहां पर कुछ करने की जरूरत नहीं है
पोर्ट स्कैनिंग की बात हो रही है ओके तो
ओबवियस बात है कि कोई भी टारगेट हमारा
होता है तो हमने जैसे कि पूरी नेटवर्क
सिक्योरिटी वा सीरीज में देखा है कि
स्टार्टिंग हम लोग होस्ट आइडेंटिफिकेशन और
होस्ट के ऊपर फिर सर्विस आइडेंटिफिकेशन से
ही करते हैं तो ओबवियस से पहले हमें पोर्ट
स्कैन करके देखना पड़ेगा भाई एनएफएस है भी
कि नहीं है अगर एनएफएस है ही नहीं तो
एनएफएस एनिमेशन करने का तो बेकार है ठीक
है तो पहले हमें देखना पड़ेगा पहला हमारा
जो काम होता है वो होता है पोर्ट स्कैन
वाला ठीक है देखते हैं आगे करने को बोलता
है कि नहीं हालांकि यहां पर लिखा हुआ है
कि आई सजेस्ट यूजिंग एप विथ हान a एंड हान
p टक्स सॉरी हान p हान टैग्स अभी हान पफ
क्या होता है आपको पता ही है ऑलरेडी कि
अगर आपको सारे पोर्ट स्कैन करने हैं तब
वरना बाय डिफॉल्ट ए जो है वो टॉप 1000
पोर्ट्स ही स्कैन करता है और एस जरूरी
नहीं है कि आपको टॉ इन पोर्ट में मिल जाए
इसीलिए आपको फुल पोट स्कैन करना चाहिए और
सिर्फ एनएफएस के लिए नहीं कोई भी सर्विस
के लिए आप एक बार आप जल्दी से स्कैन कर
लीजिए पहले कम पोर्ट्स को और फिर आप फुल
स्कन रन कर दीजिए और कशन करते रहिए कोई
दिक्कत नहीं है ठीक है अपनी मेडजी लगाइए
जैसे भी आपको पर एट लास्ट आपका एन्यूमरेशन
कंप्लीट होना चाहिए ठीक है
चलिए अब बात करते हैं माउंटिंग एन फेयर्स
अब ये माउंट कैसे होता है ठीक है उसकी बात
करते हैं उसके लिए यहां पर एक यूटिलिटी
यूज की गई है ठीक है यहां पर देखिए वही
लिखा है योर क्लाइंट सिस्टम नीड डायरेक्ट
र ऑल द कंटेंट बाय द होस्ट सर्वर इन द
एक्सपोर्ट फोल्डर कैन बी एक्सेस्ड कने का
मतलब क्या कि आपको अपने सिस्टम पे ठीक है
आपको यहां पर ओके सो जैसे ये आपका सिस्टम
है ठीक है ये आपका सिस्टम है आपके बहुत
सारे फोल्डर होंगे ठीक है इनमें से आपको
एक फोल्डर चुनते हैं जैसे मान लीजिए आप इस
वाले फोल्डर चुनते हैं और ये फोल्डर आपका
मान लीजिए य फोल्डर आपका है स्ल
टीएमपी ठीक है स्लश माउंट ठीक य आपका
फोल्डर है ठीक हैप माउंट और यहां पर ये
आपके सिस्टम प है ठीक है ना ये फोल्डर
सिस्टम अवेलेबल है आप क्या करते हैं आपको
एक्सटर्नल एस सर्वर से एक शेयर माउंट करने
की रिक्वेस्ट करते हैं व शेर मान लीजिए
स्ल
होम ठीक है स्लश आयुष मान लीजिए य शेयर है
तो जब आप इसको ठीक है स् हो आ को जब आप
माउंट करते हैं यहां से तो यह होगा कि जब
आप अपने सिस्टम पे यानी आप जब अपने सिस्टम
पे स्लश टम और स्लैश माउंट के अंदर जाएंगे
जब आप इसके अंदर जाएंगे ठीक है तो आपको
माउंट के अंदर क्या मिलेगा आपको माउंट के
अंदर वो सारा कंटेंट मिलेगा जो स्लश होम
और स्ल आयू के अंदर रखा है समझ में आ रहा
है आपको जैसे आप अपने सिस्टम में
पेनड्राइव जोड़ते हैं आप अपने फाइल
एक्सप्लोरर पे जाते हैं वहां प आपको अपने
पेन ड्राइव का एक लोके नाम मिलता है उस
टाइप करते हैं अंदर के सारे फोल्डर मिलते
हैं एज इट इज वर्क करेगा इससे आपको लगेगा
कि आपके सिस्टम प प पेनड्राइव लगी हुई है
क्योंकि वो सब कुछ काम आपके नेटवर्क के
थ्रू हो रहा होगा ठीक है चलिए अभ माउंटिंग
होगी कैसे वो देख लेते हैं ठीक है
माउंटिंग करके देखेंगे ये इसके लिए एक टूल
यूज किया गया है माउंट नाम का ठीक है ये
यटी यूज की गई है जो आपको एनएफएस कॉमन
वाले पैकेज में मिल जाएगी कंपलीटली ठीक है
तो ये सूट तो आपको पता ही क् यूज होता है
उस पता जरूरत तो है नहीं रूट की तर रन
करने के लिए ठीक है माउंट हमारी यूटिलिटी
का नाम है इसको हम यूज करने वाले हैं फिर
हमने यूज किया नटी एनएफएस ठीक है अब यहां
पर हाफ t एफएस का मतलब ये है कि माउंट
क्या करना है माउंट जो करना है सिस्टम ठीक
है फाइल सिस्टम उसका टाइप जो है वो एनएफएस
है ठीक है ए हमा प्रोटोकॉल का नाम है एस
टाइप का जो है डिवाइस है जो माउंट करना है
हमें ठीक है ना इसके बाद हमें क्या करना
है इसके बाद हमें आईपी और श देना है ठीक
है आईपी वो एड्रेस जहां पर एनफ सर्विस हो
रही है कोल ल के शेयर जो लोकेशन माउंट
करनी है अब ध्यान रहे एफएस जो शेयर कर रहा
है आप वही माउंट कर सकते हैं ये नहीं कि
कोई भी गा इसका कुछ भी माउंट कर लिया ऐसे
नहीं होता है जो शेयर अवेलेबल है माउंटिंग
के लिए आप सिर्फ वही माउंट कर सकते हैं
ठीक है ना जो शेयर किया गया है सिस्टम के
द्वारा ठीक है चलिए इसके बाद क्या ते हैं
हाफ न लॉक ये मेरे क्या से इसलिए होता है
ठीक है लिखा हुआ है कि टू यूज एनएलएम
लॉकिंग ये श इसलिए होता है कि एक साथ एक
फाइल पे कई लोग वर्क करेंगे तो दिक्कत
होने लगती है ठीक है वैसा कुछ दिक्कत ना
हो उसको अवॉइड करने के लिए आई गेस ठीक है
देख लीजिएगा इसके बारे में और ऐसे बहुत
सारे स्विच अवेलेबल होंगे ठीक है तो इसको
रन करते हैं हम लोग एक बार ठीक है इसको
मैं कॉपी करता हूं ए इट
इज कॉपी करते हम य पेस्ट करते हैं या फिर
रुक अभी रन नहीं करते पहले आगे बढ़ते हैं
क्वेश्चन के साथ इसको करते जाएंगे ठीक है
पहला चीज है कंडक्ट थोरो पोर्ट स्कैन ऑफ
योर चूसिंग हाउ मेनी पोर्ट्स आर ओपन ठीक
है हमें इस पर एक कंप्लीट पोर्ट स्कैन
करने को कहा गया है ठीक है तो हम एक काम
करते हैं पहले रुकते
हैं ये कंप्लीट पोर्टस करते इस आईपी
एड्रेस प फिहाल केलिए अभी हम सर्विस वर्जन
स्कन नहीं कर रहे ताकि थोड़ा फास्ट हो जाए
ठीक देखते हैं स्कन से य पर क्या रिजल्ट
देखने को मिलता है होली जल्दी हो जाना
चाहिए बहुत टाइम लगना चाहिए
देखते स्पीड तो काफी स्लो लग रही है
फिलहाल सि दो ही पोट पन यहां परने स्कैन
किया
है
नेक्स्ट क्वेश्चन हमारा होने वाला है च
पोर्ट कंटेन द सर्विस व आर लुकिंग टू रेट
ओके अ 10 पर हु थोड़ा वेट करना पड़ेगा हम
यहां
पर वेट कर लेते हैं थोड़ा सा तब तक आप लोग
तो मैं एक बात और कर दूं वापस से कि आप जो
भी चीज साथ में कर रहे हैं उसको मैं अभी
तक एक भी बंदे का पोस्ट नहीं देखा इस
तरीके का ठीक है आप न पोस्ट करिए आपा प
करिए हमारे चैनल प कहीं तो करिए आप अगर
सीरीज को फॉलो कर रहे हैं आपको सीखने मिल
रहा तो पोस्ट कीजिए ठीक है उससे हम
मोटिवेशन मिलता है कि किस सीरीज को कहां
कंटिन्यू करना है जैसे ये सीरीज की बात हो
गई तो ये सीरीज अभी दो तीन लेक्चर तो और
चलेगी चलेगी मिनिमम ठीक है जितना हमने तय
किया था उतना हम कवर करेंगे ताकि एक बेसिक
आपको जो है अंडर स्टडिंग हो जाएगी ये पूरी
सीरीज कंप्लीट करने के बाद इसके ऊपर से फर
अगर आपको और चीजें चाहिए सी कंटिन्यू करनी
है दूसरा कुछ चाहिए तो आप उसको बोलिए ठीक
है जो भी अच्छा लग रहा है जो भी गलत लग
रहा है जो भी दिक्कत लग रही है बताइए उस
चीज को t ग्रा प लिन प कहीं भी बताइए ठीक
है ना इस चीज के लिए आपसे कोई फीस ली नहीं
जा रही है तो आपको मेरे ख्याल से इसमें
दिक्कत नहीं होनी चाहिए चलिए यहां पर
देखते हैं वैसे तो बहुत स्लो हो रहा है तो
मेरे ख्याल से हमें इसको स्किप करना पड़
सकता है ओके ओके सो इसमें बहुत ज्यादा
टाइम लग रहा था ए स्कैन होने में ठीक है
तो हमने मास्क स्कैन ट्राई किया उसम बहुत
टाइम लग रहा था तो फिर फाइनली हमने डिसाइड
किया कि दूसरे मेथड से ट्राई करते हैं ठीक
है यानी ये हैं मैप का हम क्या करने वाले
हैं स्कैन का जो टेक्निक है वो चेंज करने
वाले हैं यहां पर आपको एक बहुत बढ़िया
एप्लीकेशन मिल गया इस चीज का कि कैसे ए
मैप का जो स्कैन टाइप होता है वो इफेक्ट
कर सकता है स्कैन को ठीक है हमने क्या
किया था हमने अभी सिंपल यहां पर स्कैन
किया था तो ये एन आप का सीन स्कैन कर रहा
था ठीक है
ऐसे तो उसकी जो स्पीड थी वो बड़ स्लो आ
रही थी ठीक है यहां पर सिर्फ दो अभी तक
हुआ है मैं आपको एंटर बटन द हूं देखिए आप
यहां पर सिर्फ 5 पर हुआ है अभी तक और ये 5
तो बहुत तेज हुआ है इसके ऊपर ये बहुत स्लो
होगा ठीक है इस तरीके से वेट करेंगे तो
अभी अपकमिंग टाइम यहां पर रिमेनिंग टाइम
दो मिनट है जोक बढ़ते बढ़ते काफी ज्यादा
हो जा रहा था ठीक है तो यहां पर हम स्कैन
का जो टाइप है वो चेंज करना पड़ेगा तो मैं
स्कैन का जो टाइप है उसको चेंज कर देता
हूं अब मैं यहां पर सिंपल टीसीपी कनेक्टर
स्कैन करता हूं ठीक है सिपल टी कनेक्ट
स्कैन अब ये काफी फास्ट हो जाएगा
चलिए ये देखिए यहां पर स्कैनिंग पूरी
कंप्लीट भी हो गई है ऑलमोस्ट ठीक अभी बस
ये सर्विस डिक्शन कर रहा है इसलिए यहां पर
इस चीज का बढ़िया एक ये एग्जांपल है कि
आपको कभी-कभी जरूरत पड़ सकती है कि आपको
अलग-अलग स्कैन मेथड ट्राई करने पड़े ठीक
है स्पीड बढ़ाने के लिए या फिर एक्यूरेसी
अचीव करने के लिए या फिर सही रिजल्ट पाने
के लिए ठीक है अब मल्टीपल स्कैन भी ट्राई
कर सकते
हैं वेट करते हैं इसके स्कैन कंप्लीट होने
तक चलिए यहां पर स्कैन पूरा कंप्लीट हो
चुका है यहां पर देखते हैं रिजल्ट क्या
आया है हमारे सामने टोटल यहां पहले ऊपर
देख लेते हैं हम लोग कि 1 2 3 4 5 6 सा
ओके सेवन टोटल पोर्ट्स ओपन है यहां पर
सेवन करते हैं सही आंसर है व्हिच पोर्ट
कंटेंस द सर्विस वी आर लुकिंग टू रेट तो
हम कौन सी सर्विस खोज रहे हैं इस टाइम
एनएफएस खोज रहे हैं देखते हैं यहां पर एस
कौन से पे है 22 पे तो ऐसे चल रहा है यहां
पर 111 पे यहां पर आरपीसी बाइ चल रहा है
ठीक
है यहां पर एनएफएस हमारा ये 2049 पे है
ठीक है यहां पर 2049 पे है ये भी उससे
रिलेटेड सर्विसेस है पर मेन जो हमारा काम
है वो 2049 पे चल रहा है ठीक है 2049 डाल
देते हैं यहां पर ओके हो गया नाउ यूज यूजर
बन एस बिन शो माउंट अब ए बीन क्या है
सिस्टम बाइनरी ठीक है तो हमें सिंपल लिखना
है यहां पर शो माउंट शो माउंट से i लिख के
आईपी लिखेंगे तो क्या होगा हमें में लिस्ट
हो जाएंगे सारे शेयर्स कहने का मतलब क्या
मतलब ये कि ये हमारा क्या है सर्वर है एफ
सर्वर ठीक है और यह जो भी शेयर्स प्रोवाइड
कर रहा है मान लीजिए शेयर नंबर वन शेयर
नंबर टू शेयर नंबर थ्री ये हमें कैसे
मालूम चलेगा कि ये कौन-कौन से शेयर
प्रोवाइड कर रहा है इसके लिए हम शो अमाउंट
का यूज करेंगे ठीक है ना कि ये कौन-कौन से
शेयर प्रोवाइड कर रहा है कि आप इसको माउंट
कर सकते हैं तो कौन-कौन से शेयर्स अवेलेबल
है कुछ भी तो माउंट कर नहीं सकते हैं उसको
हम चेक करेंगे कहां से हम चेक करेंगे शो
माउंट कमांड से तो हम रन करेंगे शो माउंट
ठीक है टप करता हूं न e फिर हमें क्या
देना है यहां पर आईपी एड्रेस दे देना है
तो यहां पर मैं आईपी एड्रेस डाल देता हूं
उसका पेस्ट करते हैं इसको रन कर देते हैं
देखिए यहां पर एक यहां पर जो है
डायरेक्टरी जो है स्लैश होम जो शेयर है
उसमें सब कुछ शेयर हो रहा है ठीक है ना
यानी स्लैश होम जो है वो यहां पर अवेलेबल
है माउंट करने के लिए अब हम इसका माउंटिंग
वाला काम शुरू करेंगे ठीक है पहले यहां पर
आंसर कर देते हैं कि हान सॉरी स्लैश होम
यहां पर अवेलेबल है अब यहां पर माउंट करने
की बात आ रही है तो माउंट करने से पहले
हमें एक लोकेशन बनानी पड़ेगी जहां हम
माउंट करना है इसके लिए हम चुनेंगे स्लैश
टेम के अंदर अभी अगर आप सीडी स्ल के अंदर
आएंगे तो यहां फालतू फाइल रखी है कोई
दिक्कत नहीं है यहां फोल्डर बना लेते हैं
अपना माउंट नाम से ये टोटली आपके ऊपर है
कि आप कहां बनाना चाहते हैं पर जब आप कुछ
स्लश टम के अंदर बनाते हैं तो हर एक
रीस्टार्ट के साथ वो सी चीज गायब हो जाती
है इसलिए हम यहां पर माउंट कर रहे हैं
उसको ठीक है ताकि वो परमानेंट माउंट ना
रहे सिर्फ टेंपररी माउंट रहे चलिए तो यहां
पर हमने एक फोल्डर बना लिया है माउंट नाम
का ठीक है हम इसमें इस फोल्डर के अंदर आ
जाते हैं अब हमारा लोकेशन अगर आप देखेंगे
तो स्ल टम स्ल माउंट है ठीक है ये हमारा
करंट लोकेशन है ये काम हमने कर दिया फिर
हमें क्या करना है अब हमें यहां पर अपना
माउंट करना है तो माउंट वाला कमांड हम लो
यहां पर पूरा कॉपी कर लेते हैं डायरेक्टली
एज इट इज ये सब काम मेरे बानी है तो आप एक
शीट रखा कीजिए सारे कमांड का जो आपको
जरूरत है ठीक है जो आपको लगती है कि
रेगुलर काम आएगी अ ये इसका ब्रेक डाउन
करते हैं अगेन ठीक है ये आप यहां पर शट
लिख रहे हैं रन कर रहे हैं माउंट टूल यूज
कर रहे हैं टाइप बता रहे हैं कि एनएफएस है
ठीक है आईपी एड्रेस देंगे हम तो आईपी
अड्रेस देता हूं मैं यहां
पर सॉरी हां पहले एक चीज मेरे ख्याल से
अभी मुझे इस डायरेक्टरी के बाहर निकलना
पड़ेगा इसको माउंट करने के लिए ठीक है मैं
डायरेक्टरी के बाहर निकल जाता हूं पहले
कहीं और चला जाता हूं उसके बाद मैं यहां
पर पेस्ट करता हूं इस कमांड को अगेन फिर
आईपी एड्रेस में यहां पर चेंज करते हैं
आईपी एड्रेस कॉपी कर लेता हूं फिर से यहां
पर मैं और आईपी एड्रेस मैंने पेस्ट कर
दिया इस आईपी एड्रेस के अंदर मुझे कौन सा
शेयर जो है माउंट करना है मुझे स्लश होम
माउंट करना है और कहां माउंट करना है मुझे
स्लश टेम के अंदर स्ल माउंट के अंदर माउंट
करना है ये हमारी लोकल सिस्टम की लोकेशन
है कि कहां पर माउंट करना है ठीक है तो सब
कुछ हमारा सही लिखा हुआ है इसको एंटर करते
हैं अब तक माउंट जाना चाहिए ठीक है माउंट
बैड यूसेज ओके यहां पर लग रहा है ओके ठीक
है यहां पर स्पेस हो गया है कलन के
बाद ठीक है यहां पर माउंट सक्सेसफुल हो
गया है मेरे ख्याल से अब हम लोग जाके देख
लेते हैं टंप और माउंट के अंदर जाते हैं
ठीक है अब इसके अंदर इस टाइम फिलहाल कुछ
नहीं था ठीक है जब हम गए जब हमने फोल्डर
कट उसके अर कुछ डाला था नहीं इसके अंदर जा
देखते हैं ओके यहां पर एक फोल्डर आ गया है
कैपेचीनो ठीक है ये कैसे आ गया है ये वही
लोकेशन है मतलब उसके स्लश होम के अंदर ठीक
है होम के अंदर जितने भी फोल्डर थे यानी
स्टार ठीक है वो सारे हमारे कहां पर
दिखेंगे वो हम दिखेंगे स्लश टीएमपी स्ल
माउंट के अंदर मतलब मतलब क्या मतलब मतलब
अगर हम लोग टप माउंट के अंदर आते हैं इसके
स्लश होम के अंदर जितनी भी चीज थी वह हम
देख सकते हैं हां इसके बाहर हम नहीं निकल
पाएंगे ठीक है बाहर नहीं निकल पाएंगे हम
जो देख पाएंगे इसलिए स्लैश होम के अंदर का
ही देख पाएंगे क् उतना ही हमारे लिए
शेयर्ड है ठीक है उतना ही हमने शेयर किया
उतना ही हमने माउंट किया है चलिए तो यहां
पर क्वेश्चन देख लेते हैं क्या है अगला
माउंट हमने कर दिया है चेंज री टू व्हाट
इज द नेम ऑफ द फोल्डर इनसाइड ठीक है कौन
सा फोल्डर है अंदर तो यहां परचीन फोल्डर
है यहां पर कॉपी करते हैं यहां पर पेस्ट
कर देते हैं
चलिए हैव लुक इनसाइड डायरेक्टरी लुक एट द
फाइल्स हमें देखनी है इसमें फाइल सारी तो
इस फोल्डर के अंदर आ जाते
हैं यहां पर कोई फाइल है नहीं मेरे खल से
हिडन फाइल्स होंगी ठीक है व डन यूजर
प्रोफाइल फाइल्स है
सारी टेस्टिंग लेट्स डू अ बिट ऑफ रिसर्च
नाउ हैव अ लुक थ्रू द फोल्डर च ऑफ फोल्डर
कंटेन कीट वड गिव रिमोट एक्सेस टू ठीक है
यहां पर कौन सी की हो सकती है जो हमें
रिमोट एक्सेस दे सकती है एस की होती है एस
की के बारे में आप जानते होंगे ठीक है य
पर वो डट एस फोल्डर के अंदर होती है यहां
पर देखिए आपकी एक की अवेलेबल है आईडी अंड
आरस ये हमारी प्राइवेट की है ये पब्लिक की
रखी हुई है चा प्राइवेट की है ठीक है
प्राइवेट की को यूज करके कोई भी सिस्टम प
क्या कर सकता है सिस्टम पे एच कर सकता है
ठीक है तो ये हमारे काम का है चलिए आगे
देखते हैं यहां पर क्या है उसकी को ले
लेंगे और ठीक है हमें उस की को लेके यहां
पर सीध सिंपल क्या करना है एच करना है व
आईपी एड्रेस य पर कॉपी कर देता हूं ठीक है
हमें क्या करना है यहां पर कॉपी करना है
इस आईडी आरएस को कॉपी करेंगे अपने होम
डायरेक्टरी प ठीक है होम डायरेक्टरी प
कॉपी हो गया मैं होम डायरेक्टरी वापस चला
जाता हूं यहां पर चेक कर लेता हूं यहां पर
आईडी से फाइल हमारी जो है व आ चुकी है एएच
करते हैं हम एसए यूजर का नाम क्या
था यूजर का नाम था कैप चनो ठीक है ज नेम
फिर आईपी एड्रेस पेस्ट करेंगे हम यहां पर
और यहां पर हमें एक्चुअली एसस की देनी
पड़ेगी हान आई करके हम आईडी अंडर आर से कर
देंगे यहां पर अब कनेक्ट करेंगे तो हमसे
पासवर्ड की जो है मांग नहीं की जाएगी और
हमारा सीधा कनेक्शन जो है वो सक्ड हो
जाएगा ओके तो यहां पर हम मशीन के अंदर
सक्सेसफुली एसज कर चुके हैं ये देखिए अब
यहां पर आईडी करता हूं तो य पर आईडी आ गई
है यू आईडी ठीक है एलएस करते हैं यहां पर
एलस ए करते हैं ठीक है तो यहां पर कोई
फ्लैग नहीं है मतलब कोई फ्लैग नहीं देना
है ठीक है कोई दिक्कत नहीं है हो यहां पर
हमारा कौन से फोल्डर से मिला है से मिला
है कौन सी की हमने यूज की है आईडी आरस से
यूज किया है ठीक है एक और इंपोर्टेंट चीज
आईडी से क बता है आपकी काम ना कर रही हो
तो आपको यहां पर कमांड लिखनी पड़ेगी सीच
मोड 600 और फिर फा आईडी का नेम ठीक है
इससे आप उसकी परमिशन चेंज करते हैं
क्योंकि कई बार ऐसा होता है कि आईडिया ऐसे
कि अगर मतलब खतरनाक परमिशन सेट है कि वो
कर सकता है तो वैसे में वो की वर्क नहीं
करती है तो की वर्क ही तब करेगी ज आप
परमिशन सेट करेंगे तो आपको ये करना पड़े
तो आप उसको कर दीजिएगा ठीक है अब पूछ रहा
है क्या हम एसेज कर पाए हैं हां हम एच कर
पाए तो इसको यस कर देते हैं चलिए अभी हमने
क्या किया एस कनेक्ट किया अब देखिए यह
बिल्कुल भी यस बात नहीं है कि एस में आपको
हमेशा ऐसी ही कोई डायरेक्टरी मिल जाएगी
जसे हमने क्या किया हमने स्लश होम के अंदर
अपने कैपन यूजर के अंदर ठीक
है चनो यूजर के अंदर हमें डॉट एस फोल्डर
के अंदर अंदर हमें आईडी यार से मिल गया
ठीक है पर ऐसा कोई जरूरी तो है नहीं कि
यही होगा यही वाला शेयर अवेलेबल है कुछ भी
शेयर हो सकता है तो ये तो एनएफएस की कॉमन
बात है कि एनएफएस प कोई ऑथेंटिकेशन या कोई
दिक्कत नहीं है ऐसा कुछ भी नहीं है तो आप
सिंपल यहां पर शेयर्स को माउंट करके अपना
जो भी डेटा है उसको देख सकते हैं ठीक है
वो वाली बात थ हमारी किस्मत है कि हमें
इसमें एसएस की मिलती है ये आपको सीटीएफ
में ज्यादा मिल जाएगा सीटीएस में आपको ये
चीजें मिल सकती है ठीक है चलिए तो अभी तो
यहां पर फिलहाल कुछ खास हमने ऐसा तो
एक्सप्लोरेशन किया नहीं एफएस का अब हम
करने वाले हैं ठीक है नेक्स्ट स्टेज में
हम एनएफएस का एक्सप्लोरेशन करने वाले हैं
मतलब ये जो हमने एएच किया है वो तो ये जो
की किया है यूज करके ठीक है एस जो हमने
किया है मशीन में इसकी को यूज करके उसमें
एनएफएस से ही भले हुआ एफएस हुआ है पर
एनएफएस का एच कोई रोल नहीं था कि एफएस की
वजह से हुआ है ठीक है इसके लिए अब हम लोग
यहां पर एफएस का एक्सटशन देखेंगे कि एफएस
में स्पेसिफिकली क्या एक्सप्लोइट किया जा
सकता है ठीक है
चलिए ओके सो एफएस का यूज करके हम लोग
बेसिकली यहां करने वाले हैं प्रिविलेज
एलेशन एफएस का काफी एक बढ़िया चीज हो सकता
है ठीक है जो आपकी प्रिविलेज एलेशन में
आपको काम आ सकता है अब ये कैसे होता है एन
फस में एक चीज होती है रूट स्क्वाश जो कि
बाय डिफॉल्ट इनेबल्ड होती है ठीक है रूट
स्क्वाश या फिर फिर आप उसको रूटिंग क
लीजिए ये बाय डिफॉल्ट इनेबल होती है ये
क्या होता है ये आपको देखिए प्रिवेंट एनी
वन कनेक्टिंग टू द एनफ शेयर फ्रॉम हैविंग
रूट एक्सेस टू द एनएफएस वॉल्यूम कहने का
मतलब क्या आपका जो शेयर है जैसे मान लीजिए
आपका होम ये वाला शेयर है ठीक है इस शेयर
जब आप कनेक्ट करते हैं तो आपकी कुछ यूजर
आईडी होती है कुछ यूजर होता है ठीक है तो
वो यूजर रूट नहीं होना चाहिए ठीक है ये
होने ही नहीं देगा ठीक है मतलब आप इस पे
इस डायरेक्टरी प रूट परमिशन कुछ भी करने
की परमिशन नहीं पाएंगे आप परमिशन नहीं पा
सकते अगर आपका ये इनेबल्ड है रूट स् ठीक
है अगर ये इनेबल्ड है तो आपका ये ब ही
नहीं है लेकिन अगर मिस कन्फेशन चलते ये
डिसेबल्ड है हां बाय बाय डिफॉल्ट आप जो
यूजर होते हैं वो होता है एनएफएस नोबडी
ठीक है एनएफएस नोबडी ठीक है लेकिन अगर
आपके पास रूट्स क्वे डिसेबल्ड है तो आप एज
अ रूट भी कनेक्ट कर सकते हैं लेकिन एज अ
रूट आप डायरेक्टली नहीं कनेक्ट कर सकते
हैं ठीक है पर आपको रूट कशन मिल सकता है
कैसे मिल सकता है बता रहा हूं आपको मैं
इसके आगे भी वनबिल बढ़ती है ठीक है फिलहाल
इंपोर्टेंट चीज ये थी कि मिसक फिगरेशन
क्या था कि रूट स्क्वा की आपकी डिसेबल
होनी चाहिए ये इनेबल नहीं होनी चाहिए ये
इनेबल है तो कनेक्ट ही नहीं होने देगी रूट
की तरह ठीक है अब ये डिसेबल है तो अब बात
करते हैं कैसे हम लोग आगे काम करेंगे ठीक
है आगे ऐसे काम करेंगे हम यहां पर एस आईडी
का यूज करने वाले हैं अब एस आईडी क्या है
आपको पता है कि कुछ ऐसी फाइल्स होती है
ठीक है कुछ ऐसी फाइल्स होती है जिसमें एयू
आईडी बिट सेट होती है अभी अगर किसी फाइल
में यानी किसी भी बाइनरी में अगर एयू आईडी
बिट सेट है तो उस फाइल को आप उसके ओनर के
बिहा प रन कर सकते हैं कने मतलब क्या कहने
का मतलब ये कि मान लीजिए कोई यहां पर फाइल
है ठीक है जैसे फाइल आपकी है मान लीजिए
नेट कट ही है ठीक है एनसी नेट कट आपका है
फाइल का ओनर आपके सिस्टम के लिए जो है वो
रूट है ठीक है रूट है और आप यूजर है जसे
आपको यूजर है जक मान लीजिए आप यूजर जक ठीक
है अगर इस नेटकट में एस यूआईडी बिट सेट है
ठीक है आप एज जैक इस नेटकट फाइल को एज अ
रूट रन कर सकते हैं समझे सिर्फ इस फाइल को
और कोई चीज को नहीं तो अब हम यहां पर क्या
करने वाले हैं एस एस आईडी बिट से हम प्रशन
कैसे करते हैं हम ऐसे करते हैं कि हम
बेस्ट शल लेते हैं ठीक है आपको पता है
बेस्ट शल ही आपका नक् का शल होता है अगर
इस बेस्ट शल प ही एयूआईडी बीट सेट होती है
अगर इस बेस्ट शल प ही अगर आपकी एस आईडी
बीट सेट हो तो क्या होगा अगर इसका ओनर अर
रूट है अगर इसका अंदर रूट है उसपे एस य
आईडी बिट सेट है ठीक है तो हम एज अ कोई भी
यूजर एज अ अदर यूजर ठीक है इस फाइल को एज
अ रूट रन कर सकते हैं तो अगर हमने बैश को
एज अ रूट रन कर लिया तो मतलब वही होगा ना
या कि आपको रूट का एक्सेस मिल गया आपको
रूट के एक्सेस में और क्या मिलता है बैश
सही तो मिलता है तो अगर आपने बैच को ही ए
रूट रन कर लिया तो आपका काम जो है हो गया
आपका प्रशन हो गया अब ये कैसे करेंगे
बताता हूं मैं कैसे करेंगे ठीक है डि समझ
गए हैं हमने एसएस कर लिया था ऑलरेडी हम
क्या करने वाले हैं ये देखिए यहां पर एक
लिंक दी हुई है इस मैं फिलहाल कॉपी करता
हूं तो ये इनके सिस्ट की कंपैटिबिलिटी के
हिसाब से दिया हुआ है ये बैश डाउनलोड करने
की लिंक है मतलब बैश शर को डाउनलोड करने
के लिए ठीक है तो हम क्या करेंगे हम ये
करने वाले हैं कि हम एनफ से जाएंगे ठीक है
यहां पर एनफ से जाता हूं मैं तो मेरे
ख्याल से मैसेज किए हुए हैं यहां पर हमने
माउंट ऑलरेडी कर रखा है तो मैं यहां पर
टर्मिनल एक और खोल लेता हूं मैं मूव करता
हूं टेंप माउंट के अंदर ठीक है यहां हमने
मूव कर लिया है ठीक है कैपन के अंदर भी आ
जाते
हैं यहां पर हम क्या करने वाले हैं हम इस
कमांड को पेस्ट करेंगे अब ये क्या करेगा
देखिएगा ये देखिए हमने क्या किया इस कपनो
फोल्डर के अंदर बैश डाउनलोड कर लिया ठीक
है बैश डाउनलोड कर लिया ये देखिए यहां पर
मैं दिखाऊ आपको अगर यहां पर मैं अलेस करता
तो आपको यहां पर बैश फाइल मिल जाएगी ये
देखिए ठीक है बैश डाउनलोड कर लिया अब हम
क्या करेंगे बैश का हम पहले ओनर चेक
करेंगे ठीक है परमिशन चेक करेंगे मैं ए ए
करता हूं तो ये देखिए बैल आपकी कहां है
बैश ये रहा आपका बेस्ट ठीक है ये आपका
बेस्ट शल है ठीक है ये इस परमिशन सेट है
फिलहाल इसका ओनर अपने आप रूट ही सेट है
लेकिन फिर भी सेफ्टी के लिए मतलब अगर आपके
नई सेट है तो आप इसको चेंज कर सकते हैं तो
मैं इसको आपको बताता हूं कि चेंज कैसे
होगा स लिखना है सीडी चेंज ओनर यानी सीओ
डब् एन ठीक है फिर आपको यहां पर वो ओनर का
नाम लिखना है फिर आपको अपने फाइल का नाम
लिखना है ठीक है इसका मतलब आपने बेस्ट
फाइल का जो ओनर है वो रूट कर दिया है
फिलहाल तो ऑलरेडी ये सेट था तो कोई दिक्कत
नहीं है अब हम इसमें क्या करेंगे देखिए
यहां पे हमने ये काम कर दिया है ठीक है
हमने इसको डाउनलोड कर लिया है सीधे उसके
अंदर ठीक है बैच डाउनलोड कर लिया है ये भी
सही है आप चाहे डाउनलोड कीजिए अपने सिस्टम
पे फिर कॉपी करिए चाहे डउनलोड कर लीजिए
मतलब मतलब वही है ठीक है अब हमने क्या
किया अब हमें यहां पर इसको परमिशन देनी है
ठीक है एयूआईडी बिट की बैच पे अब हमें
एयूआईडी बिट सेट करना है तो वो एयूआईडी
बिट कैसे सेट होगा वैसे डिब सेट करने के
लिए हमें लिखना है सुडो ठीक है सीच मोड
परमिशन जैसे देते हैं एकदम वैसे ही ठीक है
प्लस करेंगे ठीक है और एस लिख देंगे ठीक
है यानी एयूआईडी बिट की परमिशन और हमें
यहां पर बेस्ट लिख देंगे अब मैं एंटर करता
हूं अब जब मैं एलएस आफ एल करूंगा तो
देखिएगा क्या होगा ये देखिए यहां पर बेस्ट
को परमिशन मिल चुकी है ठीक है और यहां पर
ये रेड हो चुका है इसलिए यहां पर देखिए
एग्जीक्यूट यानी जहां x लिखा होता है वहां
पर अब s आ चुका है मतलब ये एक्यूट तो हो
सकता है पर एक्यूट आप कर
सकते है यानी सुपर यूजर ट कर सकते ठीक है
या फल केस में रूट है सुपर यर है ठीक है
क् देख लेते क्या य पर इसको कर लेते कौन
सा लेटर यूज किया हमने यूज किया
हैय पर चेक करेंगे परमिशन लास्ट में सब
कुछ सेट हो चुका है चेक करते परमिशन
परमिशन य लिखा आड एक् हो चाहिए मतलब अदर्स
को भी रीड और होना चाहिए को दिक्कत नहीं
हो चाहि इस से फिर भी हम यहां पर कर देते
हैं कोई दिक्कत नहीं है हालाकि ऐसे ही
ट्राई कर लेते हैं एक बार चलिए फिर इसका
आंसर करने के लिए कर देते हैं देखिए अभी
हमें क्या करना है ना यहां पर इस पूरे
कंप्लीट को कॉपी करके ठीक है इस पूरे को
कॉपी करके यहां पर पेस्ट करना है आंसर में
लेकिन इनका कहने का मतलब ये है कि लास्ट
की तीन डिजिट ऐसे दिखनी चाहिए लास्ट की
चार डिजिट ठीक है तो यहां से सब कुछ सेम
है अदर्स के पास एस यानी एग्जीक्यूट
परमिशन नहीं है तो अदर्स को हम एग्जीक्यूट
का भी परमिशन दे देंगे वो कैसे होगा हम
करेंगे उसके लिए सड सी मोड ठीक है ओ यानी
अदर्स को एग्जीक्यूट का परमिशन दे दो भाई
बैच पे अब हम करेंगे एल एल
तो परमिशन जो है वो सही सेट हो चुकी है
देखिए यहां पर x नहीं था ठीक है यहां पर x
आ गया है ठीक है तो हमारा यहां पर काम हो
चुका है इस आंसर को भी सबमिट कर देते हैं
चलिए अब हमें क्या करना है देखिए अब हमारा
एस आईडी ब तरह सेट हो चुका है अब हम इसको
रन कर सकते हैं अब रन कहां से करेंगे रन
तो एसे से करोगे ना यार ठीक है यहां पे आ
गए एलस करिए ठीक है देखिए रेड हो चुका है
ये भी अब रन करने के लिए क्या बैश को अगर
आपको रन करना है तो आपको हान प देना
पड़ेगा यहां पर आगे ठीक है ताकि ये
परसिस्टेंट रहे और अपकी परमिशन को ड्रॉप
ना कर दे ऐसा बैच थोड़ा इशू आता है इसलिए
हम ये दे रहे हैं नॉर्मली आपको ये करने की
जरूरत नहीं पड़ती है ठीक है ना तो हम क्या
करेंगे डॉट स् बश हान p ठीक है न क्या
हमने ये
देखिए यहां पर हमें अगर मैं आईडी करता हूं
ठीक है तो यहां पर आईडी ओके ठीक है हमारी
आईडी तो अलग आ रही है लेकिन हम एक्चुअली
रूट एक्सेस है हमारे पास ठीक है ये मैं
आपको दिखाता हूं कैसे मैं इसको एग्जिट
करता हूं एक बार ठीक है सॉरी एग्जिट ये
देखिए अब मैं सिंपल अगर बैश रन करता हूं
यहां पर सॉरी डॉट स्ल बैश ठीक है तो देखिए
बैश रन हुआ लेकिन यहां पर क्या आ रहा था
डॉलर आ रहा था ठीक है और यहां पर जब मैंने
डॉट बै डॉट स् बैश करके हान p लगाया था तो
यहां पर हैश आ रहा था और आपको पता है हैश
मतलब रूट का इंडिकेशन है इसका मतलब हैश के
साथ हमें रूट की परमिशन हैय हम चेक कैसे
करेंगे हम इसमें एक बार रूट प जाने की
कोशिश करते हैं अभी हमने हान p से रन नहीं
किया है देखिए परमिशन डिनाइड अब मैं क्या
करता हूं एग्जिट करता हूं और फिर मैं अब
रन करता हूं वापस से हान p के साथ ठीक है
अब मैं रूट में जाने की कोशिश करता
हूं ये देखिए हम आराम से परमिशन मिल गई है
ठीक है तो इवन दो हमने आईडी लिखने पे
हमारा यही आ रहा है ठीक है पर हम क्योंकि
यजर तो हम इसी के बि हाफ से कर रहे हैं
लेकिन हमारे पास जो शल है बेस्ट शल है वो
हमारा एक्चुअली में क्या है रूट है ठीक
ठीक है इसलिए हम परमिशन रूट की है अब हम
रूट की फाइल को रीड भी कर सकते हैं ओके
ठीक है ये हमें मिल गया इसका फ्लैग ठीक है
कॉपी कर लेते हैं इसको और पेस्ट कर लेते
हैं यहां पर आपको एक बहुत ही इंपॉर्टेंट
चीज सीखने को मिली होगी कि इवन दो आपको
आईडी कमांड जो आप चेक करते हैं हो गया कि
नहीं आप आईडी लिख चेक कर लेते हैं ऐसे केस
भी सते हैं जहां आईडी लिखने प रूट का आईडी
नहीं आ रहा है ठीक है लेकिन आपको एक्चुअली
में रूट का जो शल वो मिल चुका है इसलिए
कहते हैं कि सिर्फ आपको तरीके नहीं पता
होना चाहि आपको उसके पीछे वर्किंग क्या हो
रही है मैथोलॉजी क्या चल रही है वो तोता
जरूरी है ठीक है ना कैसे काम कर रहा है वो
समझेंगे तो आप खद समझ जाएंगे यार कि वो
रूट एक्स है ठीक है
चलिए हमने क्या कर लिया यहां पर एफएस का
कंप्लीट एक्सप्लोइटेशन देख लिया हमने समझा
एनएफएस होता क्या है फिर हमने देखा कि
एनएफएस में एलेशन कैसे किया जाता है ठीक
है फिर हमने एक्सप्लोइटेशन देखा ये जो एक्
एक्सप्लोइटेशन था वो मिसकंफीग्रेशन
अगर हो जाए रूटिंग डिसेबल हो जाए तो ऐसा
हो सकता है ठीक है अब इस पे कोई सीवी भी
हो सकता है ऐसे भी ड कर सकते हैं ठीक है
बहुत तरीके हैं लेकिन हमने जो देखा मेनली
वो मिस कंफीग्रशन बेस्ड था क्योंकि सी
चांस थोड़ा कम होता है ना लेगासी सिस्टम
पले हो जाए लेट सिस्टम प वा चीज अपडेट है
ठीक है तो कोई दिक्कत नहीं हो सकती लेकिन
मिसक फिकेशन जरूर हो सकता है मान लीजिए
बंदे ने सिस्टम सेट करते वक्त अपना एफएस
पे रूट कशन को डिसेबल किया था अपना वर्क
करने के लिए अपना वर्क कर लिया अब उसने
इनेबल करना भूल गया ठीक है तो इस टाइप की
मिस्टेक हो सकती है ठीक है ना और उसमें भी
आपको वैसे भी एएच की परमिशन तो चाहिए थी
मतलब आपको एक सिस्टम लेवल का तो एक्सेस
चाहिए था उसको बूस्ट करने के लिए ठीक है
ना तो वो भी जरूरी था चलिए समझ में आ गया
आपको एस कैसे हो रहा है नहीं समझ में आ एक
बार आप रिवाइज कर लीजिएगा लेक्चर से कोई
डाउट हो पूछ सकते हैं आप अब बात करने वाले
हैं एसएमटीपी की एसएमटीपी को वैसे तुमने
डिटेल में समझ लिया था पर इसके हम थोड़ा
एक्सप्लोरेशन और देखेंगे आज हम थोड़ा
मैनुअल नहीं देखेंगे आज हम थोड़ा ऑटोमेशन
देखने वाले हैं ठीक है एटीपी का चलिए अ
दिखा हुआ है इसका फुल फॉर्म दिया हुआ है
सिंपल मेल ट्रांसफर प्रोटोकॉल आपको पता ही
है ठीक है यहां पर ये प्रोटोकॉल पेयर इ
रिक्वायर्ड ठीक है कि यहां पर ईमेल सेंड
करने के लिए जो भी है पपा सब मैंने आपको
ऑलरेडी बता दिया है पिछले लेक्चर में
कंप्लीट डिटेल में हमने समझा था इसको ठीक
है देखिए एसएमटीवी सर्वर परफॉर्म थ्री
बेसिक फक्शन तीन बेसिक काम करता है कौन
सेंड कर रहा है ईमेल ठीक है वो दिखता है
ठीक है सेंड करता है और आउटगोइंग मेल का
सेंड द मैसेज बैक टू द सेंडर अगर मैसेज
नहीं सेंड हो पाया तो वापस जि भेज रहा है
उसको ही आ जाता है वापस ये मैसेज ठीक है
ना
चलिए ओके ठीक है यहां वही चीज लिखी हुई है
यहां पर पॉप और आई के बारे में दिया हुआ
है मैंने आपको पता था कि पॉप का दिक्कत ये
रहता है कि पॉप जब आपके किसी भी मैसेज को
रिट्रीव करता है तो वो आपके सर्वर से
डिलीट कर देता है ठीक है लेकिन आई डिलीट
नहीं करता है आई आपके मल्टी वाइड डिवाइस
से भी करेंगे आप तो वो सिंक्रोनाइज्ड
रहेगा ठीक है जो मैसेज आपने रीड कर लिया
है दूसरे सिस्टम प भी रीड दिखाएगा ठीक है
ये काम होता है आई का तो पप आई मिल के काम
करते हैं ये वाला ठीक है चलिए आपका फुल
फॉर्म आपका है पोस्ट ऑफिस प्रोटोकॉल आई फल
फॉम आपका इंटरनेट मैसेज प्रोटोकॉल इ डिटेल
में समझ लिया था फिर भी मैं आपको एक बार
रिवाइज कर दे रहा हूं हम लोग इसका एक्शन
देखने वाले हैं चलिए हाउ डज एमटीपी वर्क
ठीक है वर्क कैसे करता है वही चीज है यूजर
है भाई यूजर ने एटी रिक्वेस्ट किया ठीक है
वाइड इंटरनेट इंटरनेट के थ्रू होते हु गया
आपका जो भी रिक्वेस्ट था स थ्रू आपके रेप
पहुच गया ठीक है ना ये पूरी आपकी जो है
प्रोसीजर है ये सब आपको पता है रेडी मैंने
एक आपको अच्छे समझाया हुआ था अगर आपको
नहीं याद है रिवाइज करने नोट्स बनाया गा
तो उससे नहीं तो फिर लेक्चर आपस देख लीजिए
ठीक है ना चलिए इसको ज्यादा देखने की
जरूरत नहीं है अभी हम एक्सशन प आएंगे होता
क्या है फुल
फॉर्म
ये देखिए एल लिखा ही नहीं पह सबमिट हो गया
ये भी ठीक है यार ट्रा वालो ची सही करो
यार ए हमने लिखा ही मैं इने टेस्ट टाइप कर
टाइप करने एंटर गा दिया वो उसने वही आंसर
ले लिया चलिए कोई नहीं व्ट डज एसएमटीपी
एंडल द सेंडिंग ऑफ आंसर इन प्लूर प्लूरल
सॉरी व्ट ड हैंडल द सेंडिंग ऑफ मेल्स और
क्या आईस ईमेल्स ओके ठीक है ईमेल्स हां
ठीक कंसर इन प्लूरल लिखा था तो मुझे ईमेल
लिखना चाहिए था व्हाट इ द फर्स्ट स्टेप इन
द एसएमटीपी प्रोसेस ए प्रोसेस में पहला
स्टेप क्या होता है ईमेल सेंडिंग य होता
है यहां पर ये हो सकता है
थोड़ा अपने लैंग्वेज में चाह रहा हो ठीक
है देख लेते
हैं एसटीपी हैंड शेक ओके ओके ठीक है ठीक
है एमटीपी पहले हैंड शक देखिए द मेल यूजर
एजेंट वि इ आदर योर ईमेल क्लाइंट और
एक्सटर्नल प्रोग्राम कनेक्ट टू द सर्वर ऑफ
यो डोमेन ठीक है य बात है यूज कर रहे हैं
सबसे पहले आप
gmail.com है ठीक है उससे पहले आपका एटीपी
हैंड शेक होता है ठीक है ना चलिए इसको लिख
देते हैं यहां पर एमटीपी हैंड शेक ओके
व्हाट इज द डिफॉल्ट एटीपी पोर्ट 25 होता
है डिफॉल्ट पोर्ट व्हाट ज द एटीपी सर्वर
सेंड द ईमेल इफ द रेसिपि सर्वर इज नॉट
अवेलेबल ठीक है अगर आपका जो रेसिपि जिसको
आप भेज रहे उसको स अवेलेबल नहीं होगा तो
आपके पास ईमेल वापस आ जाता है ठीक है तो
यहां पर वापस आने के लिए कौन सा टर्म इसने
यूज किया है और देख ले हैं ओके सो यहां पर
जो टर्म यूज किया गया है वो है एसएमटीपी
क्य ठीक
है चलिए तो अगर आपका यहां पर एटीपी सर्वर
जो है ठीक है वो रिक्वेस्ट कर रहा है और
सर्वर ही फाउंड नहीं हो रहा है तो एटीपी क
में आपका जो है रिक्वेस्ट चला जाता है ये
देखिए ठीक है यहां पर लिखा हुआ है चलिए अब
देख लेते हैं ऑन व्ट सर्वर डज द ईमेल
अल्टीमेटली अल्टीमेटली एंड अपऑन लास्टली
कौन सर्वर पे आता है पप सर्वर पे जाता है
ठीक है वका रिट्रीव वाला काम होता है उस
दिन हमने अच्छे से टेल में एकदम मेल
रिकवरी एजेंट और मेल सेंट पढा था ठीक है
तो आपको याद होगा वो चीज चलिए कैन
अब एसएमटीपी को एनिमेट करने की बारी आती
है स्टार्ट कर देते हैं यहां पर मशीन को
चलिए अगेन यहां पर वही चीज दिया हुआ है कि
देखिए पुरली कंफिल बल मेल सवर कैन बी ऑफ
प्रोवाइड कैन ऑफ्टन प्रोवाइड एन इनिशियल
फुट होल्ड ऑन नेटवर्क ठीक है मतलब पुरली
कंफिल बल यानी पुराने वर्जन कोई ठीक है
दोनों आपको यहां पर दिक्कत दे सकता है और
आपको कई सारी चीजें फिंगरप्रिंट करने या
समझने में आपको इंफॉर्मेशन करने में हेल्प
कर सकता है ठीक है यानी आपको ऐसे
इंफॉर्मेशन दे सकता है इससे आप और चीजें
कर सकते हैं जैसे यहां पर हम क्या करने
वाले हैं एसएमटीपी वर्जन यूज मॉड्यूल है
है ठीक है एक मेइट का वो हम यहां पर यूज़
करने वाले हैं स्कैन करने के लिए ठीक है
मेल सर्वर्स को और एनरेटक फ्रॉम एसएमटीपी
ठीक है एएमटीपी से हम यूजर्स को ट कर सकते
हैं सिस्टम यूजर्स को ठीक है जिसे हम बाद
में ट फोर्स या बाकी चीजें कर सकते हैं तो
ये कैसे होगा ये मैनुअली तो होता है v
आरएफआई कमांड से आप क दो होगा जब मैं एमटी
आपको पढ़ा रहा था तो उस टाइम मैंने बताया
था कि कैसे आप नेट थ्रू एसटीपी से कनेक्ट
करेंगे ठीक है और आपको v आर f5 करके कमांड
लिख रहे थे और फर उस आप क्या आउटपुट देख
रहे थे कि ये यूज़र एजिस्ट कर रहा है कि
नहीं कर रहा है ठीक है वही चीज यहां पर ये
टूल्स आप क्लिक कर देंगे ठीक है तो मैनुअल
आप कैसे होता है आपको पता होना चाहिए वो
चीज लेकिन आपको एक्चुअली में करने भी आना
चाहिए ठीक है मतलब मैनुअल कैसे होरहा
बताना चाहिए लेकिन आप अपना काम जल्दी
जल्दी कर सकते ठीक है इसके लिए हम यहां पर
टू यूज करने वाले हैं ठीक है य देख व चीज
लिखी हुई है मैनली डू विद नेट कनेक्शन हाउ
एवर मेट स्पर्ट कम्स टू बी अ रेस्क्यू
अगेन ठीक है मेट स्प से हो जाएगा हम यहां
पर एसटीपी ए नाम का मॉड्यूल यूज कर सकते
हैं ठीक है तो यहां पर हम लोग कुछ चीजें
करने भी वाले हैं चलिए रिक्वायरमेंट देख
लेते हैं हमरे पास यहां परट इंस्टॉल्ड
होना चाहिए अल्टरनेटिव यहां पर दिए हुए
हैं कुछ और भी आप बहुत सारे स्क्रिप्ट या
बत स चीज यूज कर सकते हैं ठीक है लेकिन
आपको मैन पता होना चाहिए कि बिहाइंड द सीन
काम क्या कर रहा है फिलहाल हमें वो अभी
जाने की जरूरत नहीं नहीं है वो हम ऑलरेडी
जान चुके हैं पिछले लेक्चर में लेकिन
प्रैक्टिकल हमने नहीं देखा था उस टाइम ढंग
से तो आज हम यहां पर प्रैक्टिकल करेंगे
ऑटोमेशन का ठीक है चलिए पहले हम यहां पर
पोर्ट स्कैन करना है इस पे ओके इसको कॉपी
कर लेते हैं देखते हैं यहां
पर किस पोट पे जो है एप की सर्विस रन हो
रही
है चालू कर देते हैं यार इसको ओके प 25
ओपन है तो 4 25 प ही होगी मेरे ख्याल से
तो चलिए सही है हमें पता है कि इस पे तो
हम यहां पर अब क्या करने वाले हैं मैट पट
को चालू करने वाले हैं ठीक
है ओके यहां पर क्या पूछा हुआ है इफ यू
लाइक सम ठीक है व्हाट कमांड डू वी यूज टू
डू दिस ठीक है अच्छा मेट चालू करने के लिए
हम कौन सी कमांड यूज करेंगे एफ कंसोल कर
देंगे हम ठीक है चलिए यहां पर इसको मैं
क्लोज कर देता हूं कोई जरूरत नहीं है इसकी
अभी पता ही है हमें ऑलरेडी तो यहां पर हम
लोग मेटा स्पॉड को जो है चालू कर देते हैं
चालू हो रहा है ये लेट्स सर्च फॉर द
मॉड्यूल एसएमटीपी वर्जन ठीक है हम यहां पर
एसटीपी वर्जन वाला मॉड्यूल रन करने वाले
हैं इसको पहले हमें खोजना पड़ेगा तो य परट
ओपन होने का वेट कर देता हूं यहां पर
थोड़ा वेट करते हैं जब तक ये ओपन हो रहा
है आप सर्विस पोस्ट स्टार्ट कर सकते हैं
पहले ही तो वो और जाएगा थोड़ा र और कोई
बात नहीं
है चलिए स्टार्ट हो गया सर्च करते हैं
यहां पर सर्च करेंगे हम एसीटीपी एड्रेस को
वर्जन को तो य पर मिल जाएगी चलिए यहां पर
आ गया है जीरो नंबर पे है लरी स्कैनर
एमटीपी वर्जन ठीक है यही चाहिए था मेरे खल
से हमें ठीक है इसका पूरा नाम डालना
पड़ेगा यहां पर
इसके पर नाम को यहां पर हम कॉपी कर देते
हैं यार पेस्ट करते हैं यहां पर चलिए एंटर
करते हैं हो गया ग्रेट नाउ सेलेक्ट ये
सेलेक्ट करना है हमें तो आप य पर सिप सते
सेलेक्ट जीरो ठीक है जीरो क्यों क्योंकि
आपने जो सर्च किया था उसमें ये था सॉरी
सेलेक्ट जीरो नहीं यूज जीरो ठीक है य जीरो
आपने सर्च किया था उसम ये था ठीक है जीरो
नंबर प तो हमारा देख य पर आ चुका है
सेलेक्ट हो चुका हैय
चीज सेलेक्ट द मडल एंड लिस्ट द ऑप्शन हाउ
डू वी डू दिस ऑप्शन कैसे होगा ऑप्शन लिखिए
सिपल आपको ऑ दिख जाएंगे ठीक है चाहे शो
ऑप्शन लिखिए या ऑप्शन लिखिए मतलब ही है
चलिए आपको य पर आर सेट करना है आर आपका
रेडी है 25 प तो सही सेट है य पर आर होस्ट
को सेट कर लेते हैं ओके सॉरी आईपी एड्रेस
कॉपी नहीं
था आईपी एड्रेस हम य कॉपी करना है और आई
एड्रेस को य पर हमें पेस्ट कर देना है ठीक
है इसको एंटर कर देते हैं हमने आरो से कर
दिया है य पूछेगा मेरे ख्याल से कौन सा
ऑप्शन सेट करना है सेट करना है करेक्ट
वैल्यू
व द सिस्टम मेल नेम ठीक है अब हम य पर
एक्स को रन करना है
पहले न करते य पर ठीक
है2 पलो एटीपी हो ठीक यही नाम आया है इसका
पलो एटीपी मेरे ल से य होने वाला इसका
आंसर कॉपी करते हैं इसको य पर करते हैं
पेस्ट चलिए यह भी हो गया ठीक है व्ट मेल
ट्रांसफर एजेंट एमटी रनिंग एटीपी सर्वर
ठीक है दिस विल रिक्वायर एक्सनल कौन सा य
हो रहा है काम करते इसको ट्रा करते हैं
ठीक पोस्ट फिक्स य लिखा हुआ है पोस्ट
फिक्स देखते हैं
पहले ठीक है सही है एमटी पर ए एने सम पहले
से
ेंट वही चीज य पर कुछ नया नहीं है चलिए य
बेसिक इमे मिल कौन य रहा है ठीक हैट गुड
अमाउ सिस्टम ने ठीक है य पर एटी ए मडल है
उसका का यूज करने वाले हैं सर्च करता हूं
एस एमटीपी एनय ठीक है यहां पर आ गया है
इसको यूज करता हूं य जीरो यहां पर हम
इसमें आ गए हैं ओके सो ऑप्शन में अगेन
हमारे पास यहां पर आर अवेलेबल है ठीक है
तो यहां पर अपना आर होस्ट को सेट कर लेते
हैं अपना आईपी एड्रेस यहां पर दे देते हैं
ठीक है ना इसको पेस्ट करते हैं हम लोग
हमारा हो चुका है चलिए यहां पर ओके हमें
इसका पूरा लोकेशन भी देना है तो इसको मैं
कॉपी करता हूं यहां
से और इसको हम य पर सिंपली पेस्ट कर देते
हैं चलिए क्या करना है वी आर गोइंग टू य
यूज द टॉप यूजर नेम शॉर्ट लिस्ट ठीक है
इसमें क्या है कि टॉप यूजर नेम है मतलब
जैसे वर्ड लिस्ट होती है ना पासवर्ड की उस
तरीके से टॉप यूजर नेम जो होते हैं जो
मोस्ट कॉमनली होते हैं लोगों के लोगों के
अकाउंट्स के डिफॉल्ट क्रेडेंशियल के वो
इसमें स्टोर होते हैं ये आपको सेक लिट्स
में मिल जाएगा नहीं आप सड एटी इंस्टॉल सेक
लिट्स करेंगे तो आपकी डाउनलोड हो जाएगी
ठीक है कंप्लीट पूरी एक तरीके से क सकते
हैं रेपो बहुत सारे वर्ड लिस्ट है ठीक है
यहां पर भी कमांड दी हुई है आप इससे
इंस्टॉल कर सकते हैं तो ये यूजर शेयर वर्ड
लिस्ट लिस्ट के अंदर है ठीक है ना इसके
अंदर है ये कॉपी करते हैं यहां पर ठीक है
हम यहां पर यूजर फाइल में देना है ये चीज
ठीक है यूजर फाइल का ऑप्शन है तो हम
करेंगे सेट यूजर अंडरस्कोर फाइल इसको
पेस्ट करते हैं यहां पर इसके अंदर हम यहां
पर टॉप ऐ टैप करते हैं तो आ जाएगा मेरे
ख्याल से टॉप यूजर नेम चलिए नहीं आ रहा है
कोई नहीं इसको कॉपी कर लेता
हूं ये हमारी जो वर्ड लिस्ट है इसको यहां
पर पेस्ट करता हूं इसी वर्ड लिस्ट को हम
यहां यूज करने वाले हैं ठीक है अब मैं रन
करूंगा तो ये स्टार्ट हो जाएगा देखते हैं
चलिए यहां पर ये स्टार्ट हो चुका है मेरे
ख्याल से यूजर नेम ए करना अब ये क्या
करेगा आर आ वाली जो कमांड थी ठीक है उसको
यूज करके ये सार ा करेगा कौन से यूर
एजिस्ट करते हैं ठीक है
चलिए ओके कौन सा पैरामीटर सेट हम वर्ड
लिस्ट की पा देनी थी हमें यूजर अंडर फाइल
देनी थी चलिए और कौन सा पैरामीटर सेट करना
था आर होस्ट सेट करना था चलिए रन करते हैं
और वेट करते हैं लिखा है अब हमें बताएगा
कि कौन सा यूजरनेम इसने रेट किया है य पर
कोई चलिए एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर
यूजरनेम य पर इसको फाउंड हुआ है ठीक है
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर ये एक हमें मिल गया तो
एटीपी हमने अभी तक क्या रेट कर लिया
एमटीपी से हमने ट कर लिया एक यूजर नेम
यूजर नेम क्या था एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर यूजर नेम
था ठीक है एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर यूजर नेम हमें
मिल गया है अब हम यहां पर क्या करने वाले
हैं इसको एक्सप्लोइट करेंगे एक्सप्लोइट
कैसे करेंगे देखिए अब इसको हम लोग
डायरेक्टली एक्सप्लोइट नहीं करेंगे
एक्चुअली हम लोग इसको इनडायरेक्टली
एक्सप्लोइट करेंगे हमें एस तो ओपन मिला ही
था इस सिस्टम पे ठीक है प 22 भी ओपन था तो
यहां पर एच का बट फोर्स करने वाले हैं ठीक
है चलिए तो मेन वर्क हमारा यहां बस ये था
कि हमें यहां पर यूजरनेम कशन हो गया हमसे
और यूजरनेम एमेशन हो गया तो फिर आ काम
हमारा हो गया ब्रूट फोर्स करो या जो भी
करो सीटीएफ में तो अक्सर अगर आपको र नहीं
मिलता है तो ब्रूट फोर्स ही उसका तरीका
होता है मु ऐसा होता है ठीक है बेसिक ल
वाले में एटलीस्ट तो चलिए यहां पर हम क्या
करने वाले इसको एग्जिट करते हैं भाई मिल
चुका है ये काम हमारा हो चुका है इसको
पेस्ट करते हैं यहां पर कमांड को एडिट
करना शुरू करते हैं ठीक है यूजर नेम हमें
यहां पर मिल चुका है
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर वो हम दे देते
हैं पासवर्ड फाइल हमारी सिलेक्टेड है सही
सिलेक्टेड है आईपी एड्रेस हम यहां पर चेंज
कर देते
हैं सही डला हुआ है रेडी इसको रन करते हैं
यहां पर ए का ट फ चालू कर देगा ठीक है
चलिए यहां पर इसने थड को कम कर दिया है
अपने हिसाब से कोई दिक्कत नहीं है ये आपको
पता ही है हाडा के बारे में मेरे ख्याल से
तो इसको बता को है नहीं ठीक है सिंपल ब
फोस कर रहा है जहां पर उसको पासवर्ड
मिलेगा तो रेड हो जाएगा ठीक
है यह हान लगा हुआ है इसलिए वर्स मोड में
दिखा रहा है सब कुछ आउटपुट ऐसे वेट करते
हैं जब तक य पासवर्ड खोजता है बब तक
पासवर्ड खने बा सिंपल हमको य पर एटी नाम
का जो भी फ्लग मिलेगा वो चाहिए ठीक है पा
मिल गया क्या य पर नहीं अभी नहीं मिला है
ट्राई कर रहा हैय
ओके पासवर्ड मिल गया यहां
पर बहुत ही खतरनाक पासवर्ड है यार कॉपी
करते हैं इसमें एच करते हैं
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर में रेट आई एडस हमारा क्या
था आई एड्रेस 10 10 208 और
237 एंटर करता हूं मैं य पर यस करते हैं
और पासवर्ड को पेस्ट कर देता हूं कॉपी
मैंने किया था पेस्ट करता हूं दिखेगा नहीं
पासवर्ड ठीक है पेस्ट हो चुका है एंटर
करते हैं हो गया एलस करते हैं य मिल जाएगा
करते हैं
और यहां पर हमें मिल गया ू न्यू ईमेल
सर्वर्स वर कूल चलिए बढ़िया है कॉपी कर
देते हैं
इसको पेस्ट कर देते हैं पासवर्ड भी यार
यहां देना है पासवर्ड भी दे देते हैं
पासवर्ड ये कॉपी कर लेते हैं इसको भी यहां
पर पेस्ट कर देते हैं सबमिट करते हैं इसको
भी सबमिट कर देते हैं चलिए एटीपी वाला
हमारा जो इशन था वो सक्सेसफुल रहा ठीक है
तो हमने क्या किया अभी तक हमने एनएसएस के
जरिए क्या किया था ए के जरिए हमने प्रशन
सीखा जो कि उसका मेन एस्पेक्ट था ठीक है
और एसटीपी ज जरिए हमने यूजर कशन सीखा जो
कि इसका मेन एक्सपेक्ट था ठीक है इसके
अलावा कोई वर्जन एक्सपर्ट अवेलेबल होता है
तो वो अलग बात है वो डायरेक्टली सीवी
बेस्ड चीज होती है ठीक है चलिए बात करने
वाले हैं माय एसक्यूएल की ये भी काफी
इंटरेस्टिंग है इसके बारे में आप तो
एसक्यूएल बारे में जानते ही होंगे ठीक है
कि देखिए पहली बात तो ये है कि एसक्यूएल
आपका एक स्ट्रक्चर्ड क्वेरी लैंग्वेज है
ठीक है ये एक लैंग्वेज है एक सिंटेक्स है
ठीक है जिसे आप रिलेशनल डेटाबेस से बात कर
सकते हैं ठीक है तो मा एल उसी का एक
इंप्लीमेंटेशन है मतलब मा एएल इज अ
रिलेशनल डेटाबेस मैनेजमेंट सिस्टम यानी
आरडीबीएमएस ठीक है डीबीएमएस का टाइप होता
है रिलेशनल डेटाबेस टाइप जिसमें हमें कॉलम
इन सब चीजों के तरीके से रखते हैं चीजों
को ठीक है डेटाबेस क्या है सिंपली या
पर्सिस ऑर्गेनाइज कलेक्शन ऑफ स् डाटा एक
कलेक्शन ऑफ डेटा को डेटाबेस कहा जाता है
आरडीबीएस क्या होता है जिसमें हम क्या
करते हैं वर्ड रिलेशनल जस्ट मींस दैट द
डेटा स्टोर्ड इन द डेटा सेट इज
ऑर्गेनाइज्ड एज टेबल्स ठीक है यानी मतलब
क्या आपके बहुत सारे डाटा है लाइन लाइन
लाइन पूरा डटा है ठीक है इस डेटा किसी भी
डटा को आप डेटाबेस कह सकते हैं ठीक है
आपकी कोई फाइल रखी है उसमें कई लोगों का
नाम और कुछ भी लिखा है किसी भी स्ट्रक्चर
में अब उसको डेटाबेस कह सकते हैं ठीक है
अब अगर यही चीज एक टेबल के फॉर्म में
स्टोर्ड है ठीक है जैसे टेबल के फॉर्म में
है आप का यहां पर भाई तुम्हारा नाम है ठीक
है यहां पर आपकी एज है ठीक है यहां पर
आपका और भी जो डाटा है वो चीजें और यहां
पर आपकी सारी डिटेल भरी हुई है ठीक है
इसको आप कह सकते हैं रिलेशनल डेटाबेस ठीक
है टेबल्स के फॉर्म में है तो इसको कह
सकते हैं आरडीबीएमएस ल डेटाबेस मैनेजमेंट
सिस्टम ठीक है अब आपका जो आपका जो
माय एसक्यूएल है ठीक है यह भी एक रिलेशनल
डेटाबेस मैनेजमेंट सिस्टम है ठीक है सॉरी
इस मैनेजमेंट सिस्टम है ठीक है जो कि
एसक्यूएल सिंटेक्स का यूज करता है ठीक है
अपने डाटा को रिट्रीव करने या फिर अपडेट
करने या मॉडिफाई करने के लिए ठीक है ना ये
चीज था टोटल समझ में आ गया आपको ये क्या
चीज है चलिए एसक्यूएल की बात हो गई यहां
पर ठीक है बहुत सारे और भी प्रोडक्ट हैं
जैसे कि पोस्ट एसक्यूएल माइक्रोसॉफ्ट
एसक्यूएल इन सब में एसक्यूएल का मतलब येही
है कि यहां पर एएल का यूज कर रहे हैं ठीक
है चलिए हाउ डज माय एल वर्क ये वर्क कैसे
करता है ठीक है देख है माय एएल क्रिएट्स
डेटाबेस फॉर स्टोरिंग एंड ंग डाटा ठीक है
वही चीज है क्लाइंट मेक रिक्वेस्ट बाय
मेकिंग स्पेसिफिक स्टेटमेंट एएल मैंने
आपको ऑलरेडी कहा एएल एक सिंटेक्स है ठीक
है एक लैंग्वेज है ठीक हैते हैं आप जिससे
आप इंटरेक्ट कर सकते हैं तो क्लाइंट आप ही
रहे ओबवियस बात है फिर आपका रिस्पांस हो
जाएगा जो भी होगा व चीज दी हुई कुछ खास
नहीं दिया हुआ है ठीक है अब रन कहां होता
है कई सारे प्लेटफॉर्म पे होता है
ठीक है चलिए व्हाट लैंग्वेज इज माय
एसक्यूएल बेस्ड ऑन एसक्यूएल ठीक है व्हाट
कम्युनिकेशन मॉडल डज माय एसक्यूएल यूज
क्लाइंट
सर्वर व्हाट इज द कॉमन एप्लीकेशन ऑफ माय
एसक्यूएल कॉमन एप्लीकेशन क्या है
वेबसाइट्स है ठीक है बैक एंड डेवलपमेंट
होना चाहिए इसका आंसर बैक एंड
डेवलपमेंट ओके थोड़ा चेंज करना पड़ेगा
शायद हम देख लेते
हैं इसका ये बहुत लफड़ा होता है ना कि
इसको एकदम सेम आंसर चाहिए क्योंकि य बात
है सेम ही चीज चलेगा बैक इन डेटाबेस ओके
ठीक है बैक इंड डेवलपमेंट नहीं बैक इंड
डेटाबेस
डेटाबेस मतलब तो ही है या चलिए डेटाबेस
ठीक है व्ट मेजर सोशल नेटवर्क यू माय एल
देर पैक एंड डेटाबेस दिस विल रिक्वायर फदर
रिसर्च ठीक है कौन सा मेजर सोशल नेटवर्क
वेबसाइट है जो मा यूज करता है चलिए देख
लेते यहां पर फ हो सकता है लग रहा है देख
के इसकी लेंथ को सही है बढ़िया ये मैंने
इसके स्टार की लेंथ को देख के गेस मारा
ऐसा मत सोच कि मैंने पहले से किया हुआ है
ये ठीक है चलिए रेटिंग मा एल प आते हैं
ठीक हैय तो मा इरेक्शन हो गया टर्मिनेट
करते हैं इसको स्टार्ट करते हैं यहां पर फ
तो यहां पर हम आ गए हैं न्यूमरेशन पर ठीक
है देखते हैं यहां पर क्या चीजें दी हुई
है चलिए यहां पर हम क्या करने वाले हैं
यहां पर हम एक सिनेरियो एज्यूम कर रहे हैं
जाहा कि हमारे पास एक क्रेडेंशियल है ठीक
है रूट कोलन पासवर्ड ठीक है हमने अपने
सीडीएफ में या फिर अपने पेन टेस्ट में
कहीं क्रेडेंशियल पाया है ठीक है एक
क्रेडेंशियल हमने एसए प ट्राई किया और वो
वर्क नहीं किया ठीक है अब हम सोच रहे हैं
भाई ये कहां का पासवर्ड होगा कहां का
डिटेल होगा तो हम इसको एस सॉरी एसक्यूएल
पे ट्राई करने जा रहे हैं ठीक है पता है
ना आपको डेंश भने ट्राई करते हैं तो हमारे
सिस्टम में कोई क्लाइंट होना चाहिए जो
इंटरेक्ट कर इंटरेक्ट कर पाए ठीक है
एसक्यूएल से उसके लिए हम यहां पर क्लाइंट
इंस्टॉल कर सकते हैं ए इंस्टॉल डिफॉल्ट मा
क्लाइंट से ठीक है ये अगर पहले से होगा तो
अच्छी बात है नहीं हो इसको इंस्टॉल कर
लीजिएगा ठीक है तो फि क्या करेंगे इसको
कॉपी करते हैं प इंस्टॉल तो य होना चाहिए
हालाकि फिर भी य पर पेस्ट कर देते
हैं चलिए इंस्टॉल नहीं है इसको इंस्टॉल कर
लेते हैं हम लोग ठीक है यहां पर कुछ इशू आ
रहा
है
देख लेते हैं हम लोग एटी अपडेट कर लेते
हैं देन इसको अगेन रन करते हैं ठीक
है इसको अपडेट होने का वेट करते हैं मैं
आपको आगे बताता रहता हूं य पर आप
अल्टरनेटिव को दूसरे टूल यू कर सकते जरूरी
नहीं कि आप हमेशा यूज करें ठीक है ये जस्ट
एक सिंपल क्लाइंट है हमारा पहला काम क्या
है यहां पर पोट स्कन से ना है कि कौन से
पोर्ट प मा है तो मेरे ल से 336 प होता है
डिफॉल्ट इसका होता है ओके सही है तो पोट
जरूरत नहीं पड़ेगी अभी फिलहाल तो सिखाने
के लिए ठीक है बाकी आपको बाय डिफॉल्ट तो
करना ही चाहिए पोट स्कन हमेशा आपको पता
कहां चलेगा कि चीज हो रही है कि नहीं हो
रही है चलिए रन करते हैं
इसको ठीक है अ इल हो जाएगा कोई दिक्कत
नहीं है चलिए इंस्टॉल हो रहा है य पर अब
देखिए य पर करने वाले मा यटी हमने इंस्टॉल
कि अभी आ ए देके यहां पर हम आईपी देंगे
फिर आ य दे ूर नेम देंगे फर प देंगे ठीक
है
चलिए करते हैं यहां पर कॉपी करते हैं
कमांड को पूरी यहां से यहां तक ओके करते
हैं इसको इल होने का वेट करते हैं फिर
हमने जो अजूम किया पास क्रेडेंशियल कडल
क्या है रूट कोलन पासवर्ड ठीक है ेंशियल
है य पर पेस्ट करते हैं हम यूजर नेम को
चेंज करते हैं अपने हम करेंगे यूजर नेम
रूट और आईपी हम चेंज
करेंगे आईपी हम य से कॉपी करेंगे ठीक है
और आईपी य पर हम पेस्ट कर देंगे सिंपली
इसको एंटर करेंगे पासवर्ड पूछेगा ये
पासवर्ड भी पासवर्ड ही था डाल दिया मैंने
चलिए ये कनेक्ट हो गया है मतलब मा वर्क कर
रहा है ठीक है स हो गया मतलब ये माय एल का
करेक्ट डिटेल है ठीक है कडल टेस्ट हो गया
क तो सही है अब इसका कोई काम नहीं है इस
वर्क करना मुश्किल हो जाएगा अभी इसको करके
सिंपल ओपन करेंगे ठीक है करेंगे एट य से
एमएसएफ
कंसोल ओपन हो रहा हैय देख लेते य पर अब य
पर करने वाले मा अंडल मॉड्यूल ठीक है य यज
करने वाले है मायल अंडर एल मॉड्यूल अभी
क्या करता है आप देखेंगे
अभी करते इसके ओपन होने
का
इसको सर्च करता हूं मैं य
परता
सर्च य आ चुका है यूज करता हूं जीरो ठीक
है य स्क्रिप्ट है तो मतलब य कुछ इमेशन
करने के लिए काम आएगी तो कॉपी करते इसको य
पर पेस्ट कर देते
हैं इन डिसेंडिंग ऑर्डर य नहीं पूछ रहा
है कौन से ऑप्शन सेट करने की जरूरत है य
पूछ रहा है ठीक है देख लेते ऑप्शन क्या है
इसके
पासवर्ड आर होस्ट और आर पोर्ट ठीक है नहीं
ठीक है य पर पासवर्ड होगा आर होस्ट होगा फ
डिसेंडिंग डर दिया हुआ है तो प बड़ा ही
होना चाहिए य देख तो लग नहीं रहा
वैसे देख लेते हैं सेलेक्ट एंड द ऑप्शन नी
वट थ ऑप्शन ड व नीड टू सेट इन सेंडिंग डर
ओके यूजर नेम भी होगा मेरे खल से यूजर नेम
सेट करना पड़ेगा ठीक है ठीक
है ठीक है यूजरनेम करते हैं य पर यूजर नेम
सबसे बड़ा पासवर्ड फिर आर होस्ट होगा मेरे
ख्याल से देख लेते हैं यूजर नेम
पासवर्ड आर होस्ट्स ये होना
चाहिए ये नहीं है पासवर्ड आ हो देख लेते
एक बार ट देख लेते हैं इसकी ईच ऑप्शन नेम
सड बाय ए हाइ
फन सॉरी एफन नहीं अ हाइ फन ठीक है
हान तो पता यार तो आंसर देख के समझ में आ
रहा है भाई क्या ट दिया
है ठीक थड़ा बीच वाला यार छोटा है ये
डिसेंडिंग ऑर्डर क्यों लिखा हुआ है फिर
बीच वाली चीज यहां पर छोटी है ओके ठीक है
डिसेंडिंग मतलब मेरे खल से इधर से जाना है
ठीक है चलिए कोई नहीं इसका य चेंज सॉरी ये
मेरे ख्याल से होगा
पासवर्ड फिर होगा आर होस्ट फिर हो आपका
यूजर नेम सही है ठीक है डिसेंडिंग ऑर्डर
का मतलब यह था कि यहां से आपको देखना है
नीचे जाते हुए ठीक है मैं उसको लेंथ के
हिसाब से डिसेंडिंग ऑर्डर देख रहा था कोई
बात नहीं
चलिए अब हम करना है बाय डिफॉल्ट टेस्ट वि
सेलेक्ट वर्जन कमांड ठीक है ये देखिए
इसमें एल की मतलब क्वेरी है बा ल्ट वो
सेलेक्ट वर्जन है ठीक है रन करेंगे तोय इस
क्वेरी को रन कर देगा ठीक है अा ओके आ
नहीं किया हमने इस आई करना
है न करते हैं इसको य रन कर देगा ठीक है
एक्सेस
डिनाइड क्या दिक्कत आ ग
भाई हमने चालू किया थाना इसका
वाला
चालू यूजर नेम भी सेट नहीं कि हमने यूजर
नेम पासवर्ड को सेट ही नहीं किया यार हमने
सीध रन ही कर दिया है
सॉरी यूजरनेम यहां पर सेट करते हैं यूजर
नेम हमारा था रूट और पासवर्ड हमारा था
यहां पर पासवर्ड अब रन करते हैं
इसको चलिए आ गया ये हमारा वर्जन जो है
हमें मिला हुआ है ठीक है ये हमारा वर्जन
हो गया एसक्यूएल का कॉपी करते हैं इसको
यहां पर आकर पेस्ट कर देते
हैं चलिए वर्जन मिल गया ठीक है अब मा चल
गया सब कुछ सही काम कर रहा है ठीक है यहां
पर चेंज एसक्यूएल ऑप्शन टू शो डटा बेसेस
ठीक है अब यहां पर हम डेटाबेस देखेंगे
मतलब यहां पर हम कमांड दे सकते हैं कौन सी
कमांड रन करनी है तो हम करेंगे सेट
एसक्यूएल शो डेटा बेसेस ठीक है अब अगर
ऑप्शंस दिखाऊं मैं आपको तो ये क्या सेट हो
चुका है यहां पे सेट हो चुका है शो डेटा
बेसेस अब मैं रन करूंगा तो ये सारे डेटा
बेसेस दिखाएगा ये देखिए इंफॉर्मेशन स्कीमा
मा एएल परफॉर्मेंस स्कीमा और सस ये चार
इसमें डेटाबेस है ठीक है थोड़ा इसके बारे
में समझते हैं ये हाउ मेनी टा कितने आए
हैं चार आए हैं टोटल चलिए अब इसको
एक्सप्लोइटेशन देखते हैं एक्टेशन पार्ट
क्या है इसका अभी तो हमारे पास क्या है अी
हमारे पास एएस मा एएल सर्वर क्रेडेंशियल
है जो कि हमारे रूट और पासवर्ड थे ठीक है
नेक्स्ट वर्जन है कौन सा वर्जन रहा है पा
नंबर डेटाबेस है कितने डेटाबेस है इसम
उसका नाम है हमारे पास ठीक है अब कुछ
टर्मिनोलॉजी स्कीमा क्या है स्कीमा आपके
बहुत सार डेटाबेस के बारे में डिटेल्स
रखता है वही चीज है ये ठीक है इस देख सकते
हैं और भी इंफॉर्मेशन स्कीमा नाम से जो है
यही वाला है ठीक है ना इंफॉर्मेशन स्कीमा
परफॉर्मेंस स्कीमा ठीक है चलिए हैश क्या
होते हैं आपको पता ही है कि पासवर्ड हैश
होते हैं आप कोई भी मतलब अपना अगर सिक्योर
रखना चाहते हैं पासवर्ड को अपना तो आप प्
टेस्ट नहीं रखते उसको हैश करके रखते हैं
ठीक है अगर कहीं से वो लीक भी हो जाता है
तो उसको क्रैक करना आसान ना हो ठीक है
चलिए देख लेते हम यहां पर एक मडल य करने
वाले हैं स्कीमा डंप ठीक है जो हमें
स्कीमा डंप करके देगा तो यहां पर करते हैं
वापस से सर्च इस तरीके सेट बहुत सारे
मॉड्यूल है जो आपके मैनुअल वर्क को बहुत
ज्यादा एफिशिएंट कर देते हैं ठीक है इसका
लोकेशन दे जरत नहीं है लोकेशन देना है
चलिए सबसे बोरिंग काम लगता है या कॉपी
करना चलिए कोई नहीं कॉपी करते हैं इसको
यहां पर और पेस्ट कर देते हैं
फिर पेस्ट हो गया है हमें क्या करना है रन
करना है सिंपली इसका ऑप्शन सेट करके ऑप्शन
देख लेते हैं क्या
इसके पासवर्ड सेट करना पड़ेगा हमें यहां
पर
अपना यूजर नेम सेट करना पड़ेगा हमें अपना
ठीक है आर होस्ट सेट करना पड़ेगा हमें
अपना आर होस्ट हमारा यही इसको कॉपी करते
हैं वापस से पेस्ट कर देते हैं यार रन कर
लेते
हैं चलिए आ गया य पर जितना भी स्की में था
ठीक है व पास आ गई है य लिखा हुआ है वट द
नेम ऑफ द लास्ट टेबल ट गेटस डम लास्ट कौन
सा टेबल था टेबल है
अभी करते हैं लास्ट टेबल नेम हमारा यह था
इसको पेस्ट करते हैं यहां पर हो गया एम यू
हैव नाउ डम द टेबल्स एंड कॉलम नेम्स ऑफ द
होल टा बेस मतलब पूरे टा बेस जितने टेबल
है जितने कॉलम है य सबका नाम आ गया है ठीक
है ना देख सकते हैं ऑलरेडी
चलिए बट वी कैन डू वन बेटर सर्च फॉर एंड
सेलेक्ट माय स् हैश डंप ठीक है अभी तो
पूरा डंप हुआ है पूरा डपम खोजते र जाएंगे
आप ठीक है हम ये यूज करना वाले अब य क्या
हैता आपको य क्या करेगा पेस्ट करते य पर
ठीक है आपका आ गया जीरो नंबर प य जीरो कर
देता हूं पहले मैं इसकी भी लोकेशन देनी है
ठीक है चलिए इसकी भी लोकेशन देनी है इसको
करते य पर से
कॉपी करते फटाफट से पेस्ट ठीक है अगेन हम
य पर ट करने रन करने है तो हम करते हैं य
पर
ऑप्शन सेट करते य पर
पासवर्ड पासवर्ड ही है करते यूजर नेम जो
की रूट है
करते हैं आर होस जो कि हमारा ये आईपी
एड्रेस है कॉपी करके यहां पर पेस्ट कर
दिया जाए रन कर देते हैं इसको भी ठीक है
ये देखिए यहां पर हमारे सामने जितने भी
हैश थे वो आ चुके हैं ठीक है जितने भी यूर
के है थे देखिए यहां पर क्या अन आई विल
लेट यू टेक इट फ्रॉम हियर ठीक है अब यहां
पर खुद सेट कीजिए सब कुछ काम करिए ठीक है
व्हाट नॉन डिफॉल्ट यूजर स्टैंड आउट टू यू
कौन सा स् आपको यूजर लग रहा है जो कि नॉन
डिफॉल्ट है तो यस मा स् डिफॉल्ट होगा रूट
तो रहेगा ही खैर ये भी रहेगा ही डेन
सिस्टम भी लिख डिफॉल्ट ही होगा रूट रहेगा
ही कार ये कार नाम लिख रहा है तो कार्ल
यहां पे लिखते
हैं करेक्ट आंसर ठीक है अब हमें क्या करना
है अब हमें इस इस हैश को कॉपी करके क्रैक
करना है ठीक है काल का हैश यहां से यहां
तक है ये ये उसका हैश है कॉपी करते हैं
ठीक है अब इसको हमें क्रैक करने के लिए
कहा गया है व्हाट इज द यूजर स्ल है
कॉमिनेशन कार्ल कोलन फिर ये है पेस्ट कर
देते हैं चलिए सही है अब इसे क्रैक करना
है तो यहां पर दिया हुआ है कि आप जॉन द
रिपर टूल यूज करके क्रैक कर सकते हैं ठीक
है फिलहाल हम यहां पर ऑनलाइन टूल यूज करते
हैं देखते हैं यहां क्रैक हो जाता है कक
स्शन इस इस्तेमाल कर सकते हैं टाइम सेव
होगा बहुत ज्यादा आपका हैश पेस्ट कीजिए ट
पर सेलेक्ट कीजिए और क्रैक गाइए चलिए यहां
पर क्रैक हो चुका है इसका रिजल्ट है डॉगी
वा क्या पासवर्ड है भाई चलिए पासवर्ड इसका
डॉगी ठीक है इससे आपका बहुत सारा टाइम बच
सकता है तो इसको आप जरूर से बुक मार्क कर
लीजिए इस वे साइट कोने ठीक है चलिए एम
पासवर्ड ू इ नॉट ओनली एक्सट्रीमली डेंजरस
बट एक्सट्रीमली कॉमन व्ट आर द चांसेस ट
दिस यूजर हैज यूज दे पासवर्ड फॉर डिफरेंट
सर्विस ठीक है व द कंटेंट ऑफ मा ठीक है
इसका मतलब य है पासवर्ड लोग यूज बहुत करते
हैं या कोई हिंट दिया हुआ है कि भाई दूसरी
सर्विस ट्राई करो अब दूसरी सर्विस आपकी
कौन रन हो रही है दूसरी आपकी रन हो रही है
एस यहां पर ठीक है तो आप करते हैं एच @ एच
काल @ फिर अपना आईपी एड्रेस दे देते हैं
जो कि यहां पे है 10 10 75 एंड 141 ठीक है
उस यस करता हूं और पासवर्ड में पासवर्ड
क्या था आपका
डॉगी देखते हैं देखिए लॉगिन हो गया ठीक है
एलस यहां पर मिल गया हमें
ठीक है इस कॉपी कर लेते हैं यहां पर ये
बता रहा है कि ह्यूमन डसी है पासवर्ड यूज
करने की इसकी वज से कितना लॉस हो सकता है
मतलब मा एल वहां पे हमने एक्सट किया और
माय स् की वजह से हमें यहां का एक्सेस मिल
गया ठीक है ना इसको पेस्ट करते हैं यहां
पर सबमिट कर देते हैं चलिए हो गया कंप्लीट
फर्द लर्निंग इसी चीज की रिवीजन है कुछ
यहां रिसोर्स मिले हैं आप इससे एक्स्ट्रा
पढ़ सकते हैं इसको फिलहाल कंप्लीट करते
हैं रूम हमारा जो है वो कंप्लीट होता है
यहां पे टर्मिनेट कर देते हैं इसको और
उम्मीद करता हूं कि आपको ये वीडियो पसंद
आया होगा आज का वीडियो काफी ज्यादा
प्रैक्टिकल था ठीक है और आपको यहां पर जो
भी चीज आपने सीखी है उसको आप लि
पे शेयर कीजिए हमें टैग करके शेयर कीजिए
हमें भी मान चलता है भाई कि स् आप करके
रहे हैं साथ में कर रहे हैं कि नहीं कर
रहे हैं ठीक है हमें मोटिवेशन मिलता है
भाई ये कौन सीरीज कंटिन्यू करनी है कौन स
सीरीज नहीं कंटिन्यू करनी है वो सारी
चीजें उसके बदले आपको कोई पैसा लग नहीं दे
रहे अगर आपको अच्छा लग रहा है तो बोलिए
बेकार लग रहा है तो जो भी रिव्यू है उसको
दीजिए ताकि हम उस पे इंप्रूवमेंट कर सक
ठीक है ना चलिए तो आज के लेचर के लिए इतना
ही करते हैं मिलता हूं नेक्स्ट लेक्चर में
आपसे तब तक के लिए बाय बाय